uh so I guess the big story today video
was going viral showing this black dude
in St Louis very slowly and very
casually load up a handgun at first it
seems like he's got a jam or something
and then he just over the course of a
minute and a half prepares the weapon
and then kills a homeless guy now
initially I was seeing reports that it
was a white homeless guy some people in
our sporting it was reporting it was a
Hispanic homeless guy I'm not super
worried about that necessarily the big
issue is the decay of cities and now
we're seeing these things go viral that
uh I gotta be honest things like this
probably happened in cities a lot over
the past several decades but we're
seeing it here and it's kind of waking
people up to the societal Decay that's
happening all around us that this guy
was loading up a weapon no one did
anything nobody tried to stop him just
filmed filmed it happening and it's
reminiscent of that story we got out of
Philly where a dude
let's just say
violently assaulted a woman
I'm trying to be I'm trying to be family
friendly in the first 30 seconds of this
show here
in the first minute and everyone just
watches as he as he pins her down and
has his way with her that people just
watch and film and that seems to be the
way things are going so we'll talk about
that and then in response to this we're
actually getting more commentary what's
going on with Scott Adams the creator of
Dilbert the context around what he was
saying and now people reacting well a
lot of people are reacting Elon Musk
came to his defense not only saying he's
funny and shouldn't be canceled but that
the media is racist against Asians we'll
talk about that plus more close calls
with Airlines people are mad at Buddha
judge and a former Obama staffer is
saying that Joe Biden's gotta go before
we get started head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work
click that join us button and become a
member because we do a Live members only
show Monday through Thursday at about 10
10 p.m once the live show wraps up we
then go live again and we can get some
of your comments in for now we're
building a Discord out so that you can
chat with us live and even call in to
the members only portion of the show but
as a member you make all this possible
we're only able to do it because members
basically fund the whole operation we
are ad supported to a certain degree but
you may notice we don't read a whole lot
of ads all the time on the podcast side
of things a little bit but uh it's
because we would rather have you be the
customers than some corporation who's
trying to buy access to you being the
customer and that means we're going to
try and do right by you and not buy some
Corporation it also means if they come
to us and they say hey we don't like
you're saying these things I'll be like
I don't care you're not a customer the
customer is the viewer who becomes a
member at timcast.com so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more we have Aldo budazone thanks so
much for having me man appreciate it uh
who are you what are you doing I'm Aldo
butazoni I'm a prageru personality
living out in La fighting on the uh the
front lines of the culture war and happy
to be here man thanks for having me
right on we also got Hannah clay bremelo
hi I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com
there you go and Phil Labonte what's up
I am filibonti lead singer for All That
Remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary and our homie
what's up I am at surge.com hey
handicraft push that Mike a little bit
in front of you I just never know what
I know what uh it's all good it's gonna
be louder I need to like yell
yeah perfect we think that Ian watched
my morning show segments and just saw
how dark everything was today and
decided I'm just gonna I'm just gonna go
I'm going to bed called up Phil and
fulfill you got a feeling for me man
it's too much I can tag in his you know
you know the thing about Ian is that he
tries to see the good in people all the
time and it's really difficult to do
with this viral story and the things
that we have in today's news so maybe he
just needed he needed a break Ian is
such a gentle wholesome Soul he is he's
like I want to Pardon bad guys even
Stalin he wants to Pardon bad guys the
worst people and he also believes that
the government should be uh an
authoritarian monster Because he
believes in benevolence and God I love
him he's adorable he's a sweetheart
quoting Ann Coulter over there I just
want to hug you all right let's jump
into this first story we got this from
timcast.com homeless man executed in
broad daylight on St Louis sidewalk
there's a clip of uh of what happened
just before the shooting um We're not
gonna play the video now I will say the
video doesn't actually show the
execution it shows right up into the
point of it you see the guy slowly
loading the weapon he's like shaking it
and then there's someone narrating
behind glass like watching it happen
being like he's hey you just put a
magazine in it's like don't you realize
what he's about to do here's the crazy
thing about this story so apparently
they caught the guy I guess but the
crazy thing is when the dude is about to
load the magazine you know he has no
access to he's not he's unable to use
that weapon at that current moment
nobody wanted to do anything
so we got two things out of this story
for one I want to make sure I point out
stories like this probably happen a lot
in big cities and by a lot I don't mean
like every single day
but frequent enough I've seen stuff in
Chicago that would make your your blood
boil and uh sometimes people just
randomly shoot other people and things
like that this is one of these stories I
think people were shocked by this the
reason the video went viral is not just
that you're seeing this this callous
murder but that no one cares to do
anything anymore Carl Benjamin from the
Lotus Eaters podcast says this is a
social contract you don't have to do
anything so why would you you no longer
have to protect anyone else so I was
thinking about this and just to kick
things off I was thinking about I did
this segment on you know feminism and
stuff the other day
about gender roles and why we have
certain cultural traditions and it's
because we want to survive and so we
survive better when we're together
that's why a single person out in the
middle of the woods might end up dying
but with 10 or 15 people they can work
together and distribute the the workload
and end up Surviving but now that we
live in this sterile mechanized cyborg
Society no one knows each other and no
one cares and it seems like
I guess the side effect of absolute
luxury of humans being able to drink
sugar I mean just think about crazy look
at this I got I got another Coca-Cola
tonight I don't know why you can
probably tell me talking fast but we
we've extracted sugars and Hyper
concentrated now we just drink it and
that's something that you don't find in
nature for the most part maybe fruit
juices but even that you're not getting
this much we have so much luxury we
literally just don't care about anybody
else
back in the day
you're in the middle of the woods you're
like please we got to work together
we're gonna die now it's dude we've got
so much food in the shelves you're
actually pissing me off get away from me
and so when stuff like this happens
people just don't care but I think it's
also like people don't feel a connection
to other people in the public like what
connects us anymore it's not religion
it's not our ethnicity it's not our
culture everyone has their own little
cultures everyone has their own little
groups and I think when you put
everybody together in big cities like
this we are living in a very mistrustful
Society um this reminds me this thing
we're talking about reminds me of I used
to spend Summers out in Montana
and we used to buy some of our produce
and products from this group of people
called the Hutterites they're like the
Amish with a little different things and
what they would do is they would make
their communities and after it got to a
certain size around 100 people they
would start another little colony
because they realized that you cannot
feel a connection to somebody when your
Society gets too big when their colony
gets too big and you're not seeing the
person that's working for you putting
food on your table cleaning your beds
whatever it is you lose that connection
and you lose the I think the the
humanist instinct to you know put
yourself out there for other people and
I think that we're seeing that on a
large scale in society that nobody feels
this connection nobody feels this
obligation to care about one another we
just we just don't need so much of it
and you know it used to be you did the
work you had to do and then other people
would do work that would complement your
life so you know one guy grows the wheat
another guy Cooks it and makes it into
bread and then you you share the guy
with the wheat says okay I'll give it to
you he says okay I'll make bread and
then we'll share the bread now it says
we have machines doing everything so
it's kind of like I don't know know you
I don't care you provide nothing for me
you're a threat to my life and thus we
disconnect from each other and then you
see this the same thing that makes a man
sit there and just film and other men be
killed is the same thing that makes that
man kill that other man but there is
just no connection I think that the the
one of the things that's not that you
guys haven't mentioned is the fact that
if anyone does help and they they hurt
the guy that's got the gun they're gonna
go to jail yeah the state's going to
prosecute yeah why should there's no
incentive to intervene yeah like
Universe incentive everyone knows that
like I'm a gun guy right I'm a very Pro
2A guy like I've got opinions that are
as Extreme as Tim or more extreme
um I carry a gun all the time like
everyone knows it if I'm in a place
where you know I'm not supposed to have
a gun and I happen to have a gun I'm not
doing anything I'm not helping anyone if
I'm in a place where I can have a gun
and I know that that it's an unfriendly
District like in a like a D.A would
prosecute me for for intervening I'm not
helping but not only that even if you're
in a place with constitutional carry you
run the risk of civil liability
absolutely you'll get sued in some other
state or who knows what like I remember
years ago watching videos out of China
where this same kind of thing happened
where somebody would get run over or
someone get attacked and nobody did
anything because the same thing happens
that we're talking about is they just
say I don't want to intervene because
the liability is too high and that's
we're still just uh on the on a getting
run over thing I heard that they will
kill you if they hit you in the car the
liability is more if you survive than if
you die if they kill you they go to jail
for a few years if they permanently
injure you they're they got to pay pay
for your life for the rest of their
lives so what they'll do is they'll get
out look at the person and just run them
over finish them off the level of apathy
that we're seeing in our society is very
disheartening it's not just apathy it's
actively avoiding situations that put
you in the crosshairs of the government
do you think this is the negative side
effect of the Live and Let Live
mentality no if you're watching this
you're like I know something bad's gonna
happen but I I don't know what the
context is I shouldn't intervene there
might be something like do we think that
we have bred a culture that feels like
they are supposed to stay out of
everything I think maybe maybe but I
think that it's when it comes to
violence that we've significantly
disincentivized people from acting on
behalf of their fellow humans because
the government or the government will
allow people that are risking their
lives to save other people the
government will allow those people's
lives to be ruined look at Kyle
Rittenhouse right like you don't even if
you don't like the situation with Kyle
and think he shouldn't have been there
Etc that doesn't matter the D.A went
after him and they're still going after
him yeah they're they're trying to go
after him the kid that literally had a
gun out and that he shot in the arm that
survived who said he wanted to kill Kyle
Rittenhouse who said I wish I unloaded
in him told his buddy there and that
they're allowing reportedly yeah
reportedly they're allowing that kid to
still bring a civil suit well the risk
to reward ratio isn't even worth it like
you said somebody intervenes and they
think to themselves well if I put my
life on if I risk my life and I do help
this guy and he does survive all right
and he does get prosecuted what he's
going to go to jail for a year he's not
you're not taking a murder off the
street for his entire life you might get
him off the street for a little bit so
the reward isn't there for people and in
St Louis was at the end of January this
year there was a 17 year old who pled
guilty to shooting at a police officer
and he wasn't even given jail time he
was given less than a year of the social
work program so I mean the laws just
aren't in favor of the law-abiding
citizen it's empowering criminals
because they know that they're not going
to get prosecuted for for murder just
about remember the mccloskeys no tell me
about them the mccloskeys live in St
Louis and a bunch of black lives matter
Riders broke the fence to their private
Community walked in and the mccloskeys
came out with guns on their own property
and said back off get away and the
mccloskeys got arrested had their guns
confiscated and then ended up having to
cut some deal or something I think the
governor stepped in on their behalf and
pardoned him or or something and said
you know you decided that they they
weren't Prosecuting but the D.A wanted
to prosecute which is ex and now inside
in St Louis this is where this guy gets
killed so the D.A
prosecuted or tried to prosecute them
kloskeys and then
demonstrated you are not in a position
to defend yourself or anyone else
because ideology and now now you have
this example of what happens obviously
one is not led to the other directly but
when you have a
the notion that you cannot defend
yourself or others you don't get people
helping out the mccloskeys got charged
with two felony counts of unlawful
unlawful use of a weapon weapon and
tampering with evidence for having guns
on their own property it's ridiculous I
mean every it's just ridiculous when you
have law-abiding citizens who feel
fearful for protecting themselves and it
really does empower criminals and it
makes me think about the Michigan State
University shooting because I went to
Michigan State University I graduated
last year I saw friends there I have
loved ones there I have family that goes
there and that's a gun-free zone and so
again that's another example of
empowering the criminals while
law-abiding citizens do not have the uh
I guess just the resources or the you
know feel the ability to protect
themselves I'm a concealed pistol
license holder in the state of Michigan
and I carried almost everywhere I went
the one place I never carried was on
campus when I went to school there and
so when I think about that and I think
about me graduating last year
if I didn't have I wouldn't have had a
gun on campus I couldn't have protected
myself or others if I was in that
situation I'm thankful I wasn't but the
fact is there are three students at MSU
that aren't alive that should have been
um you know would that have would the
gun free zone save those people I don't
know but again it's about inching away
and taking away step by step our rights
um and and the feeling of our ability to
to protect ourselves and does the
gun-free zone make them targets right if
I wanted to do something wrong and
wanted a place to do it I would go to
the place where I knew people weren't
armed right right if you're already
going to commit a crime you don't care
if you're violating uh the gun-free zone
right and I moved to Texas after I
graduated and I'll say that I carried
every day there it's an open carry state
and I've never felt safer I saw people
with guns on their hips all the time and
I it was a very nice feeling to be quite
honest yeah
cultural decay
I don't know man I think your point
about the size of community is worth
noting uh Andrew Heaton who does the
political orphanage podcast he had an
episode that was recently saying what's
the optimum size of community because at
a certain point you just don't know
people and therefore you're unable 300
or is it like 3 million because like
whatever but that is very difficult to
govern right like if you had 300 people
well you mean a whole bunch of if we had
uh I don't even know how many it would
be in America but hundred thousands of
300 people community that would be very
difficult to regulate or to coordinate
efforts across the state the the issue
is not so much the size of community it
is to a certain degree it's a lack of
culture it's a lack of morals right so
you can have 20 billion people and if
each and every one of those people
believed that if they did wrong they
would burn for eternity then they might
not do wrong however we've got it we've
got people of all different views and
all different faiths who do not agree
and some in fact believe believe they
are obligated to strike down blasphemars
and apostates in which case you get more
because of that that Faith system I
think that if people in this country all
had an agreement on say like the Golden
Rule then you wouldn't have to you
wouldn't even need police officers you
wouldn't need police with a billion
people if everyone agreed on the
morality but they don't and some people
are predators who want to exploit and
harm other people and so now you've got
stuff like this and I guess you combine
the a growing civilization more and more
people
with the fact that our culture is
fragmented and breaking apart and
digital media is creating decentralized
networks and tribes
it's gonna get worse right so we used to
have with just the five big TV networks
everybody believed the same things but
now with the internet some people watch
show like this some people watch other
shows what you're gonna end up with is
small pockets of different tribes who
are just untrusting of other groups and
then you get stuff like this man yeah I
mean but at the end of the day we are
you know we're human beings and we do
have instincts to want to be around
people that think like us that look like
us even
um and that's why you have when you have
homogeneous societies they are very high
trust societies look at Japan I mean
it's very homogeneous everyone looks the
same talks the same has the same culture
and here in America we have every
ethnicity we have every religion we have
every type of culture and as human
beings that have that you know
instinctual need for community and for
people that share the same values and
morals that becomes difficult when you
cram everybody into one city and say you
know do your thing like good luck and
that's why I even see this guy that's
been going viral on Twitter recently
this black guy in New York like he's
yelling oh yeah minority like he's
terrorizing the city
um and just yelling at him so I do think
it comes down to Shared values shared
religion you know shared morals
let's get controversial with it we have
this tweet from Elijah Shafer that he
put up shortly before the show and it's
the image from the execution with
Dilbert and it says quote there's no
fixing this and um obviously it's ingest
but he's making a point about what Scott
Adams said and Scott Adams uh the
creative Dilbert flows aren't familiar
he did a show where he basically was
talking about the effects of critical
race Theory the effects of the left's
racial views and he was talking about
how racial tensions are getting worse
and worse the more they fan the flames
and and then he he said
hyperbolically I might add and they took
it out of context that he would
encourage people to get away uh he would
encourage white people to get away from
black people this is what of course
Elijah Schaefer is pointing to here's
here's why I wanted to bring this up
the first thing I want to say is because
we talked about Scott Adams things last
night is that it seems like after he if
you look at the full context of what he
was saying and a lighter clarification
he did not believe the Rasmussen poll
was sound data he was making a point
about if the data were true and this is
what we're seeing with the expansion of
CRT then he's saying fine if that's what
the left wants this is the advice you'd
have to give to somebody in fact Scott
Adams was actually saying that he would
advise based on critical race Theory and
diversity hiring and stuff a black
person to move to an all-white area so
that he could get the diversity job
because that's the system created by
critical race Theory so he was actually
being very critical of this and was
opposing segregation and it's uh but I
think he dropped a nuke on the
conversation on purpose the reason why I
wanted to highlight Elijah Schaefer's
tweet in the context of this uh
execution in broad daylight is that
whether Elijah is intending to express
actual concern or just making a joke
being like look this guy making a meme
about it people are going to feel this
way people are going to see what happens
with Scott Adams they're going to hear
what he said he says then they're going
to see this video going viral and it's
like millions of views and they are
going to take it to a racial place so
the problem I have with what's going on
I mean first of all our culture is
decaying and it's because of what
they're doing in schools what they're
teaching kids they're teaching them
weird cult ideologies about how you know
minorities can't succeed and things like
that which is generating hatred and
animosity
you've got ABC News Univision funding
and organization this is the company I
worked at Fusion where the
editor-in-chief's Twitter profile says
down with whiteness and I'm like what do
you think happens when you go around
telling people to hate each other based
on race the funny thing is they're mad
at Scott Adams about it
you'll get things like this again not
not saying Elijah for is taking it
literally I think he's he's memeing and
being you know edgy on purpose but
there's going to be a lot of people in
this country who are going to look at
that and say yes
and that's a function of the left
they've been pushing for segregation in
every corner of our society for years
you know they call for segregation in
schools they they create black only
dorms in elementary school they teach
kids that America is fundamentally
racist and so for the left then to go
and you know claim and uh you know that
I was essentially saying that you know
if this is what you're calling for then
fine and then calling that that race
it's like you can't have it both ways
you can't claim that we should segregate
and then somebody says okay and then
call them racist for it they are going
to try to have it both ways they have
arguments prepared for people that say
that you can't have it both ways the
arguments won't make sense unless you
understand their lexicon they share a
vocabulary but they do not share a
dictionary the things that they say when
you say racist they will have double
meanings whether it's a position of
power uh and privilege or if it's a
whatever Prejudice whatever whatever
fits there attempt at winning an
argument yeah and I mean therefore they
win in chaos right when people disagree
they Thrive a lot of times it boils down
to a fundamental philosophy that is
illiberal they are a lot of times you
get consequentialists on the left that
believe that whatever they do is okay if
the consequences are good they are the
and the the most important point is they
are illiberal the the left has moved
Beyond liberalism it is now Progressive
so they do they support things like
segregation because they believe that
present uh discrimination is what fixes
past discrimination and the only thing
that will fix present discrimination is
future discrimination these are things
that are ubiquitous and the left
currently and it's infested Palo friary
school programs and the curriculum it's
a horrible thing that's going on and we
need to get Paulo Ferrari's influence
out of schools I was thinking about this
you know because we were out here where
we are we're away from the cities we got
local farms you drive five minutes from
here and there's a farm stand with
grass-fed organic beef and the funny
thing is they don't call it that they
just call it ground beef but it's
because it's from a farm the cows ate
grass and then they like they didn't put
chemicals or anything in it and I was
thinking about that as so I tweeted
something but I'll ask you a sort of
Correction here's how I feel
conservatism is organic grass-fed beef
not because it's a premium product
because that's literally the way you
raise cattle you let it walk around
eating grass liberalism modern you know
neoliberalism is GMO fed genetically
modified uh corn it's corn fed
genetically modified cloned beef mass
produced at a low price and available at
your local supermarket and Progressive
progressivism is
plant-based beef with a pH food product
available in your your vegan food aisle
and I I do feel like you know it's a
silly joke but it does kind of exemplify
a lot more than just
the meat the meat argument like I was I
was talking to a friend about where they
could get you know farm fresh meats or
whatever I thought about it I'm like man
if you go to like the Corporate Center
you're going to get corn fed GMO beef or
whatever and if you go to the farm
you're getting the good stuff but the
farmers are all conservative I thought
that was kind of funny and uh but but
it's it's everything else I mean think
about what what schools are like for
your average liberal it's March and
lockstep it's the it's mechanized
machine it's the high fructose corn
syrup plastic bottle but then you look
at what's happening now with
progressivism seeping in and now it's
the crazy gender ideology CRT race-based
everything and it's it's it's it's crazy
because it's it's it's imploding on
itself in a sense
they claim racism is a problem while
actively being racist it's it's it's
it's an amazing Paradox but I guess it's
just destroying the foundations of our
institutions and ripping the culture
apart it's resulting in people hating
each other and fighting dividing
concrete it's feeding racial tension
there's this Gallup poll from 2019 and I
hate to bring up another poll I know no
we don't love them this week but uh in
2019 they found that for the first time
since the poll started in 20 2001 uh
more black Americans are saying race
relationships with white people are at
an all-time like they're the worst
they've ever been they're they describe
them as the majority of black people 59
describe race relations with white
people as bad but white people didn't
have this perception right and this is
before everything that happened with
George Floyd and our very very public
discussions of race especially when it
comes to white versus black Americans
This was 2019 it was the year before I
think that we've had like you were
saying uh conversation about race that
actually don't heal communities and
don't encourage understanding they pit
people against one another and there's
no you sort of can't be surprised when
we have this cartoonist saying like well
this is where we're headed perhaps we
should all split up take a look at this
uh this is a a quote from a news article
it says Adams is currently embroiled in
a public Scandal following advice he
doled out last week when he told white
people to get the hell away from black
people citing a poll that found nearly
half of black people are not okay with
white people it's like okay well hold on
there that's not really what the poll
said and Scott Adams said he was being
hyperbolic and he even said he does not
think the data from that poll is
absolute or sound and he thinks people
should be treated like individuals but
his point was like if there's a poll
that tells you half of this group of
people doesn't like you you probably
don't want to be around them I mean so
imagine if you put it the other way and
it said the poll said half of white
people didn't want to didn't think it
was okay to be black and then someone
told black people to to fear or get away
from white people that's literally what
this the critical race theorists are
doing right now well this is literally
what the left wants the liberal says
that race isn't the most important
factor about you it is the content of
your character the left says no actually
your skin color does determine your
worth your skin color does determine if
you will be successful and it reminds me
of the the Morgan Freeman clip where he
says you know how do you get rid of
racism will you stop talking about it or
Aegis Elba recently came out and he says
I want to stop being known as a black
actor I just want to be an actor and
then today this clip going viral of Issa
Ray saying that you know I'm rooting for
black I'm just supporting anybody who's
black that's winning and it's crazy that
today we still have to point out that
you are not valuable based on your
immutable characteristics that it is
your abilities it is your talents it is
the work you put in but the left doesn't
want that they want you to be
constrained and confined by your
immutable characteristics because then
they can control You by them happy and
content people do not uh engage in
Revolutionary activities
period they don't the the left desires a
revolution because they are illiberal
they don't like the principles that this
country was founded on the liberal
principles that this country was founded
on they want a revolution so the more
people that are unhappy and dissatisfied
with their lives the better for the left
period that's the way that it is because
you don't get revolutionaries from
content happy satisfied people if your
Society is is mostly happy and most
people are satisfied and most people
feel good and have hope for the future
you don't get Revolution why risk it why
why risk the good things you have going
right now what they have to do is
convince people that things are bad so I
saw this viral video of some kid and
he's like I live with my parents and my
girlfriend because I can't afford rent
because to even get some place to live
like a studio or one bedroom it's like a
thousand bucks per person that's insane
how can anyone afford that right make
sure that people can't afford to live
and you guarantee yourself a revolution
so
maybe that's why they're building
bunkers in New Zealand because they're
preparing for something that uh I guess
we can all see coming and probably
should prepare for too
I mean I don't want to talk about the
possibility of like crazy International
globalist creating a nuclear war to kill
off a bunch I didn't say anything about
that I I'm talking about economic crisis
in which you get socialism and so they
have ranches in New Zealand
but these this this is literally what's
happening the wealthiest people in the
world are building these properties in
New Zealand having bought citizenship
there having bought citizenship there
and other places like Saint Kitts and
Nevis you can buy citizenship there and
then you're looking at all the failed
policy brought about by the Democrats
and the The Establishment Republicans
which result in 2 000 bucks for a studio
apartment a person can't afford then you
get a bunch of young people saying this
is the worst ever been the system is
impossible what am I supposed to do and
then Along Comes A Marxist saying hey
agree with me and then we'll take it
from everybody and say sure why not I
can't get it anyway
so that's literally happening whether
intentional or not is it doesn't matter
yeah I think one of the interesting
things about all conspiracy theories is
that if a thing is happening and then
someone comes out and says I believe
thing happening is the result of a
person wanting it to happen they say
yeah you're a conspiracy theorist but
you then come out and be like I got no
idea why but things happening and well
is that a conspiracy no I never said
anybody who's doing a purpose like like
population reduction how about this how
about we're seeing across the around the
world countries are are seeing their
populations decline you've got people in
the United States sterilizing their kids
aborting their kids or just outright
advocating not to have kids with climate
change
it's happening climate reduction I'm
sorry um population reduction is
literally happening now the question is
can you prove an individual or
individuals have been implementing these
policies with the intentions
specifically of reducing population well
the answer there is yes not all of it
I'm not saying every single instance of
every single uh active that reduces
population I'm saying Bill Gates goes on
stage and says we have to reduce
population so the funny thing is this is
a conspiracy theory that powerful Elites
have advocated for and talked about
incessantly that there are too many
people since what the 70s the methusian
ism or whatever
and then you've got Klaus Schwab you've
got Bill Gates you've got these powerful
Global Elites saying here are the things
we're going to do to reduce population
growth then you start seeing policies
implemented that reduce population
growth okay fine I'm not saying young
women are being encouraged to get
abortions because Bill Gates is funding
super Pacs or anything like that I'm
just saying sure is can great for him
that the thing he wants to happen is
happening you know so it happens people
want it to happen there you go that's as
far as I'll go with it
yeah I actually just got done finishing
um filming a documentary with Prager
University about masculinity and one of
the people that I interviewed was John
Gray he wrote the book boys are from
Mars Women Are from Venus and he talked
about this one experiment I forget the
name of it it was like this rat
experiment but he essentially related to
the breakdown of the gender roles and
when you talk about depopulation you
know he he talked about this that how
the Utopia experiment
maybe yes yes exactly um yeah and so you
know and the breakdown of the gender
roles and how men and women aren't
interacting as much there was recently
this Pew research research poll that
showed that men aren't dating anymore
women aren't you know the dating and
women are down but you know he talked
about how our homosexual population is
also growing and how that's contributing
to depopulation so I don't know to what
scale but I thought that was interesting
what John Gray brought up well this is
interesting because we've talked about
it's like the mouse Utopia or the right
Utopia experiment basically this dude
put a bunch of mice in this big in this
big space and gave him all the food and
water they could want and then just left
like there you go Utopia everything
you'd ever want and eventually they
their society broke down some became
aggressive some stopped procreating
there there were some there called the
beautiful ones uh Shane Cashman wrote
about this beautiful ones of universe 25
that they would just groom themselves
all day and just make themselves look
prettier and pretty they won't mate
they're just obsess themselves they
won't mate but the male rats will still
have sex sex
well they would they were like all
cluster in one room together like
there's this their social order broke
down they just stopped functioning
properly and then eventually they all
died
and uh it sounds a lot like what we're
seeing now like there is a there is a
limit to Live and Let Live I guess like
obviously fascism is bad okay people
need to have freedom and leeway to live
their lives and be productive but then
if you get to the point where you're
like you literally don't care that adult
entertainers are putting on Children's
shows like adult entertainment for kids
is bad obviously but the left the
Liberals they're cheering for it it's
like okay I think we're entering the rat
Utopia phase where our society ceases to
exist I guess the difference is
we have we can see it and we know the
results of these experiments so I think
worst case scenario
Society breaks down completely people
become aggressive and start killing each
other which kind of seems like it's
happening and then Preppers who are
active pay attention and read build
bunkers ranches and then humans are just
they end up fine in the long run yeah we
get through I think I think you see
people withdraw from society right I
mean you talk about this all time
leaving cities we know a lot of people
who switched homeschooling during the
pandemic they decide that they don't
want to be a part of the society so they
sort of as much as possible with
throughout special it's not it's not
totally possible you still use the
grocery store your kids still have
friends who go to public school that
kind of stuff but they actively choose
to try and put distance between them and
what are signs of society's collapse
yeah well it's it's what you said uh Tim
about in the beginning about having
everything in the convenience culture
has evolved to the point where we don't
need human relationships we have
everything we need you know we we don't
need you know relationships to gratify
our sexual urges which is very innate in
us we have pornography we don't need to
make our own food we have ubereats and
we just have grocery stores where we
pick it off the shelves we don't have
danger to make us need physical fitness
and endurance and you know fighting off
dangers we literally don't need each
other anymore and that is killing us
dude you want to hear something really
crazy I make millions of dollars
complaining about on the
internet and I I am astounded every
single day because I grew up in a way I
grew up in a place where I was like if
you don't work you don't eat and I'm in
the city it's like I I I I would play
guitar in the subway when I'm basically
borderline homeless because I'm like I'm
gonna find a way to make money otherwise
I'm not eating and that's what you had
to do and now I'm at a point where it's
like turn the camera on complain people
listen and you make money doing it I'm
not saying that to be self-deprecating
for the most part I'm saying there isn't
we have we have as a society gotten to
the point where there are people who
don't actually work
and they live like kings this is the
craziest thing like we're all Kings now
this is not this is not feasible in the
long run it is not a viable way for
Human Society to function that right now
there are people whose hands are covered
in in or their hands are calloused and
every day they're lifting things they're
constructing things and they make
substantially less than a buzzfeed
writer there is a person who works at
BuzzFeed well not anymore they're
replacing it with AI it's going to get
even worse I guess or maybe maybe better
maybe people will be forced to start
working again but there are people who
work in the corporate press who show up
to work in the morning and they're like
uh what should we do today
um You can call Trump a Nazi and they're
like okay yeah I'll do that and then
they make 90 000 a year meanwhile people
at home listening are like I drove a car
around for 12 hours you know doing
deliveries and I made 50 to 100 bucks
how can a society function when you have
a class of when you have working class
actual working class people who work and
then you have the Elite ruling class and
corporate press that do nothing and
extract 10 times the value from the
system now that is a recipe for disaster
in my opinion that can't sustain itself
yeah I mean when you talk about
animosity like that that'll fuel
animosity Tim
um and I think that some of the things
we mentioned aren't accessible to the
people who are making you know 50 to 100
a day the BuzzFeed writer can spend all
day on the internet and can get ubereats
and whatever else but if you live in a
rural community and you don't have the
budget for that you are forced to
interact with your your neighbors in
your world a little bit more and I think
that is one of the reasons it's so
separate I know I mentioned a couple
times but the CDC released their youth
Behavior study and they found basically
that teenage girls are really the
majority of teen girl is very sad very
unhappy who are the most social
creatures naturally on Earth teenage
girls they look for Community all they
want to do is talk to friends but their
society more and more is digital right
teens are on their phones they're
interacting on Snapchat they are looking
for gratification through likes on
Instagram as opposed to in-person
accomplishments we are leading them into
their own destruction and we're just
saying no it's great because we have
comfort now and it's so nice the
internet I think it's I think it's funny
that it's I think it's funny that it's
the wealthy trust fund lefties that
think they're the oppressed working
class you know there's like that viral
video out of I think it was Seattle
where a bunch of anti-amazon protesters
are you know leftists are protesting and
then the actual Amazon workers show up
in hard hats and like vests and they
start shouting them down like the actual
working class guy is like a 35 year old
white dude named John who voted for
Trump not a you know 30 year old hipster
named Devlin who you know took feminist
basket weaving at college but they think
their working class and they live in
cities their lives are funded by this is
the craziest thing to me about how the
system works college loans right now
everyone's screaming like Joe Biden pay
off our loans oh no the loan forgiveness
and you've got these these protesters
these unions and they're screaming being
like they need to forgive student loans
and I'm like it's just crazy to me that
these hipster leftist types literally do
no work get free money from these
institutions then demand everyone else
eat the cost and pay for their entitled
lives and there's a dude out there right
now who's listening to this show at work
lifting a heavy box and his back hurts
and he's thinking yup that's but that
the the thing is they don't think that
they're the working class they're
they're leninists and they think that
they're the Vanguard they think they
they really do they they're Marxist
leninist that's where that's the basis
of their their opinion they're the ones
that are the the Bourgeois they're the
bourgeoiselle yeah they're the Bourgeois
that are gonna they're the Bourgeois Pro
that are gonna that are gonna sweep the
proletariat through the revolution into
the new Society into the social Society
that's exactly what they think everyone
that's that's at Media Matters thinks
that they're a one a member of the
Vanguard they're all going to get the
bullet if they get what they want
because that's what the commies do oh
yeah the the Communists Purge the
Intelligentsia that fomented the
revolution in the first place yeah
liberal get the bullet too so they're
done but but the Communists know who's a
real risk the working class guy or the
Revolutionary the Revolutionary so once
the revolution happens the
revolutionized turn on each other but I
got an idea here's what we should do we
should do one of those like panel
discussions that you see on the internet
every so often where they'll get like
you know two layers of chairs and then
have people all sit there and like a
person ask them all questions and I just
want to get like working class Union
guys from Western Maryland and West
Virginia and then College hipster
leftists and then just be like let me
ask you guys some questions who did you
vote for and then watch all the working
class guys be like oh yeah I work in a
factory I work in a steel mill I voted
for Trump and then the college student
is going to be like but you're working
class why are you voting for Trump I
voted for Biden it's like you have no
idea our problems dude but this this is
the fundament fundamental difference
between the left and the right the left
base the left bases their life around
rights where the right bases their life
around obligations and that's what the
left does is they say you have all of
these rights and if you vote for me I
will give them to you and the right
things I don't have rights the only
rights I have is the right to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness I
have an obligation to my family I have
an obligation to God I have an
obligation to my country I would say the
left promise is entitled elements they
would say things like you deserve this
this is yours but they frame it as
rights they you have a right to Health
Care you have a right to food you have a
right to this wage you have a right to
everything a hundred years ago we we
only have those three rights the right
to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and you need it to build you
need it to farm you need it to fight and
because we don't have the need to do all
those things they can come up with all
these rights and then again say you have
these rights and if you vote for me I
will give them to you I will I will give
you all of your desires but just because
that again comes back to the fact that
they're not liberals they're they're
progressives they believe that they
don't believe in rights at all they
don't believe in in
the rights are what the government gives
to people and that's all they believe I
just part of me really would love it if
the system just stopped for one month
just one month but but I know the
reality is a lot of people would die and
I don't want that to happen I just want
these purple hair shaved head leftists
who cry because someone misgendered them
I just want them to understand a little
bit what hard work really is and how
hard life really is for other people
because while these people are at
Starbucks crying because someone
misgendered them there is a 12 year old
kid mining Cobalt with his teeth falling
out of his face who's doing the work to
make sure they can have their espresso
machine and they have no idea they are
these people exemplify capital city in
The Hunger Games so perfectly they don't
realize that they watch these movies and
they're like I'm Katniss it's like no no
you're that Capital City crazy-haired
lady drinking ipicac and barfing to eat
more food at your party not realizing
other people are being beaten and
enslaved so they can sustain your way of
life I think that there are other people
too even in these colleges I one of my
good friends growing up or that I went
to high school with put himself through
college while working as an EMT full
time and he got his degree and he kept
going like he's one of the hardest
working people I know and I think if
anyone in his college had been like I'm
working class too he would have laughed
but he wouldn't have said anything
because what he doesn't need to prove
himself to them I think that the people
who have never been asked to consider
like they you know they take on student
loan debt knowing that someone in their
family will be able to help them pay it
off or they don't need to think about it
they are resigned to not being
responsible for the consequences of
their actions and then when eventually
they are at they're put in a position
where they have to act with
responsibility or to meet their
obligations they don't want to do it
anymore this is the problem though
there's a there probably conservative
types with Cal's hands sit there with a
smile on their face looking at the
hippie liberal being like If Only They
Knew man a whiny little you know whiny
little and they don't say
anything
and it's because they're hardened and
they're not phased by the complaints of
these people but the squeaky wheel gets
the grease so these lunatic leftists go
around smashing things and screaming and
then
feckless politicians are like just give
them whatever they want they're yelling
in my ears yeah I saw a tick tock I saw
a tick tock the other day some kid was
literally saying why do I have to work
just to live oh my gosh and I'm like
really oxidization that's what I say
oxidization I'll try and get it to the
root for you dude it's called entropy
that's it your body is is ceasing to
exist without being sustained by energy
and you have to get it from somewhere
ain't nobody can do it for you it's
amazing that people think that there's a
meme that went around for a while that
was like I blame my parents for this I
didn't ask to be born so I didn't ask to
like pay for all this anyway
and you you're gonna be like so you'd
rather be dead like what that's why
they're first yeah they are foreign
they're also saying that like they
should never have to assume
responsibility right like life is a gift
and being able to live life on Earth is
something is a blessing and so therefore
like don't look at your parents be like
how could you do this to me how could
you bring me on like into this world be
grateful and become mature and accept
your responsibilities in life
I forget the Philosopher's name but he's
like this is not some kind of new thing
that there was a philosopher hundreds of
years ago talking about the flungness of
existence the the the way that you kind
of just are tossed into reality like
that's part of the human condition shut
the hell up and quit whining no it
pisses me off when I go online and I see
people my age and they're like I had
such a hard day at school like I just
need to unwind it's like what do you
mean unwind you read books for six hours
unwind for what can you imagine like
talking to a 50 year old guy that's been
working on the docks in the 60s he comes
home and you're like how was your day
like how are you feeling he'd look at
you and you go what do you mean how am I
feeling I need to put food on the table
what do you mean I gotta get up in eight
hours are you kidding me but we have
this sense of entitlement in my
generation that yeah you need to have
your relaxation time you need to have
your vacation time you need to have a
little cookie at the end of your meal
you need a little sweetness it's like no
no you have obligations to again your
God country and your family and the left
has stripped all those things away and
said you have all these rights you are
the government is your daddy
and it's left to everybody sad depressed
anxious like obligation and working for
people outside of yourself working for a
higher power working for things anything
outside of yourself that's what gives
you fulfillment that's what gives you
gratitude that's what gives you a
meaningful life I want to jump to this
story from the Daily Mail New York
teacher manipulated fifth grade student
into changing gender without parents
consent which drove her to consider
suicide lawsuit claims it was only after
the girl nine Drew suicidal images that
her parents found out teacher Deborah
rosenquist was calling her Leo and using
he him pronouns superintendent Jennifer
J Quinn and Terryville Road Elementary
School principal Anna Marie V skiov Skov
admitted they knew about rosenquist's
antics
so we'll just uh look at this I mean
just one weird whoa I'm so surprised of
my lungs aren't you surprised that
that's what she looks like you guys but
think about this there there is a there
is a little girl who knows and believes
she is a little girl and the teacher
keeps saying no you're a boy and your
name is Leo causing such distress that
the nine-year-old contemplated suicide
it's almost like these people are
demonic and I say that figuratively not
literally I don't believe in demons I
just don't think well I guess you can
call some things demons I just don't
think adults should have secrets with a
nine year old from their parents right
the fact that she's not saying like hey
your kid is expressing some confusion
about their gender or whatever like if
that happened in your classroom go
immediately to their parents you're an
adult you shouldn't have secrets with
children 100
it's so obvious I just don't understand
like why is this even a question and
then this idea that like oh well their
parents wouldn't be accepting well maybe
it's because they're nine and you're a
stranger and you don't have any right to
tell a kid what their what you know like
you said if it will be accepting or not
that is for the family they have
whatever beliefs they have that is for
the child and the parent but today
children have become the vehicles and
the medium for people to project their
social and political views onto and then
that way they can use kids in any
example to say well what about the kids
if you don't affirm their gender then
they're going to commit suicide if you
don't let me take them to a drag show
then they're going to commit suicide and
it's like no no that is for the parent
to decide you do not get a relationship
with that kid outside of what the parent
is doing and that is the definition of
grooming you always get these claims I
get them all the time oh we're not
groomers you're calling everyone a
groomer if you're doing anything to lead
a child down a path that goes against
what the parent is teaching you are
grooming them whether it's sexual
political whatever it is that is the
definition of grooming
well and then also how else would we
bring to these hearings right I remember
listening to public radio in West
Virginia when they had one of their uh
like can you give hormones to underage
children and they're like just listen to
this Brave testimony from a 12 year old
who identifies as transgender you want
to be like this person is 12. they
shouldn't be here why are they the
political tool of essentially the
pharmaceutical industry and their messed
up parents and teachers like this is
crazy somebody posted uh I think in like
Massachusetts they have an
anti-sterilization law that says that
any doctor that performs a medical
procedure that sterilizes a child that's
guilty of a felony I think it was
Massachusetts and they're just like how
come not this is not being prosecuted
like how come not going after people who
are doing this that seems like one of
the most obvious things that that you
can imagine like if a doctor performs a
a a surgery or whatever on a child
without the parents uh consent uh they
must be like even me for them there are
some high schools in California that
have planned parenthoods attach them or
they're like on campus and they'll offer
you know referrals for birth control
they can't prescribe there but they'll
also offer referrals for hormone therapy
or any kind of like transgender issue
may have
why why would you not want to be
involved in what's going on with your
minor right I understand if that
person's 18 they're an adult and that's
a different argument but School
shouldn't be facilitating private
conversations with adults without the
parents presence that seems so obvious
and yet we just abandoned this principle
all the time I mean the word yeah you're
right it's obvious well they're
introducing a bill in Florida right now
that would make businesses who offer uh
payment for gender gender affirming care
to their employees to be responsible for
the D transition cost if there is regret
this was a bill that was introduced I
think a couple weeks ago and it'll be
interesting to see how that plays out
because I can imagine that businesses
are going to say wait hold on if they
regret this if I offer them surgery they
do something that they regret and I will
be liable for their detransition
hormones or surgery whatever I may not
want to take that risk and it'll be
really interesting to see how businesses
respond to this
I just think that they'll they'll say
yeah we'll do that because we don't
think that many people will uh will
detransition I think that we as a
society not we in this room but
generally people are not willing to
acknowledge the risks that are like
you're bringing up uh sterilization
sterilization laws in Massachusetts
they're not enforcing it because they're
not saying it's definitely for sure
going to sterilize you there's a chance
it might I mean the studies are pretty
clear on what the consequences of some
of these uh interventionists either
hormonal surgical treatments are for
people who identify as transgender but
there's enough gray area where they're
skating by saying like well but maybe
it's helping because they're depressed
or whatever else like this is going to
be it's going to get worse before it
gets better right because the data is
living in this gray area even though
Common Sense tells us one thing we have
enough uh ambiguity in the Medical
Science to deny it well if there's
anything that made me believe in
possession by demons it's stuff like
this like the weird cult-like behavior
that we've seen from the woke left the
inability to process information and the
rejection of fact now maybe it's not
demons it's just that some people can
get put in a cult-like trance but it
sure does feel like demonic possessions
it's not it's not Supernatural but it's
probably what people were describing
when they started calling people
demonically possessed like the behaviors
were the same when like as they were
trying to figure these things out you
might call them psychotic nowadays or
whatever but like when you say evil
there are behaviors that people can
engage in that will qualify them as evil
because they fit the definition the word
has a definition if you engage in these
activities you are evil there are things
that you can do that are demonic that
qualify as a definition that doesn't
mean that there's actually like
Supernatural like 10th Dimension demons
living
like there were you know like
interdimensional beings and I don't mean
like demons from other dimensions I mean
demons in between the dimensions you
know like in between realities and the
twisting now that the demons come out
you know they do their thing I call it
what you want I think it's semantics but
you know if there was a word for it uh
grooming miners into the radical left
gender ideology that has them chemically
castrate and generally mutilate
themselves evil that would be it evil
yeah
I feel like sad because they just prey
on parents who are scared right if I
told you your kid is suicidal and if you
don't do this one thing they'll die I
mean there are a lot of parents who
would be like I'll do anything to keep
my kid alive the issue is the kids are
suicidal because of the teachers exactly
that's what they say listen to how
predatory this is they say to the
parents would you rather have a boy
daughter or a dead daughter
imagine as a parent's daughter a
translator yeah when they're going in
for these these gender surgeries and
their consultations they tell the
parents would you rather have a boy
that's a girl or would you have it would
you rather have a dead daughter think
about that as a parent think about a
medical professional that you should
have some trust in saying you either
have to medically chemically castrate
your child and give them these these
drugs or they will kill themselves that
is predatory and lay on top of that well
and you didn't know they were going
through this and the teacher had to tell
you which means your kid doesn't feel
comfortable with you like it's just
Guilt Trip after abusive guilt trip I
feel sad experience hopefully have
enough common sense not to do this I
don't feel bad for the parents who are
like no this is a good idea let me bring
my child to political rallies and prop
them up as a representation of what a
good woke parent I am but I do think
that there is at some core you know I
think a lot of parents are scared and
they want to do the right thing and I
think the fact that this industry is
preying on this because that's what it
is it's an industry is just disgusting
and I I can't believe that this wouldn't
be be an obvious point where we unite as
a culture and say this is bad but
apparently we can't which is
mind-boggling it is an industry you
trans a child you have a patient for
life and that's a lot of money yes
there's there's a lot of things that are
actually lining up that that are have a
certain Synergy so you've got the
financial incentive from hospitals
you've got the ideologically possessed
uh people that are looking to actually
mess up Society they want their
ideological and want a revolution you
undermine the structure of the family
exactly exactly and then you've also got
a lot of a lot of your default Democrats
right your your knee-jerk I want to vote
to be nice people which is the majority
of the Democrat Party right the the
people that are actually
thought leaders are are the ones that
are probably you know the the committed
leftists your average foot soldier for
lack of a better term is a is a soccer
mom that just wants to do what's right
for her kids and wants to like not make
waves at the PTA meeting too much
because she wants everyone to get along
because they might bump into each other
at the Starbucks on Tuesday you know
it's it's that stuff really has an
effect on people so the motivation or
the the incentive doesn't have to be
some cabal that's handing out uh you
know cue drops or whatever it it can be
just the common uh General narrative
that people are believing and people
trying to do what they think is the
right thing yeah I think it's terrible
to put children at the center of this
and I think that's why the left is so
willing to do it right because I think
there are so many people who are
compassionate they realize that children
don't aren't able to have advocate for
themselves fully and they are ultimately
um you know a lot of our law looks at
them as basically obsessions of their
parents but they are in a lot of respect
even though they have they are people
with rights and they know that basically
you get a two for one voter right so if
you get the parent to support you and
the kid goes through it they're probably
also going to support your cause it's
it's Mass recruiting people to your side
of the line and that's terrifying
because it has intense real consequences
for those involved you know that saying
Missouri loves company
laughs
yeah I've heard something like that yeah
might have been a little different it is
kind of weird that when people are are
living in a self-indo induced I'm just
thinking about it I want you to live in
it as well you know what I mean they
crabs in a bucket crabs in a barrel they
don't want you getting out they want you
to suffer if they have to suffer yeah
well have you ever met like have you
ever had a friend that they base their
entire personality around problems that
they have and them like these are
problems that are so fixable they would
be so easy to fix but they get more out
of having the problem and the attention
that they receive from it than they
would if they just fix the problem and
you have these you have these groups
that they they bond over their problems
and then it's like when people fix them
and they leave the group they're they're
demonized right they're
so it's weird and that's what you're
seeing I think on a societal scale that
when you have a victim class it's easy
to control it's easy to feel good about
yourself there's no self-accountability
there's no self work that you have to do
if you're a victim then you will always
have someone to blame and you will never
have to fix your problems yeah I I think
there are people that are so negative
that just complain about everything and
that person's not doing the right thing
by them whatever else and you walk away
feeling negative and you just don't want
to hang out with them again for a while
and I think we're seeing this on a mass
scale right so if you're a young person
in society and all of your friends are
upset about something and then you open
Twitter and everything's everyone's
complaining and fighting and then you
look at the news and everything is bad
like how could you not start to feel
just totally black pilled let's jump to
the story we got from Yahoo news it's
actually a syndicated from the National
Review San Francisco reparations
committee chairman admits no math
formula behind a five million dollar
payout plan that's right they're going
to write a five million dollar check to
each black resident and they didn't use
a mathematical formula to determine that
they just decided that's that's the
number I guess plus like a lifetime
guarantee of Revenue but uh although
you're just mentioning that people build
communities and personalities around
Grievances and I have to wonder if one
of the reasons we're never actually
going to see reparations is because
these political groups need it as a as a
political culture as a tool to win power
yeah no I agree
this plan is going to cost billions of
dollars San Francisco it's like I think
twice the budget of like the city budget
like they cannot afford it and they're
like it doesn't matter we'll just say
yes and figure it out later it's crazy
that they that like they haven't figured
it out yet that they are political pawns
until the end of time if they keep
saying well we're going to give you this
because you're black we're going to give
you this if your ancestors were slaves
it's like what if you're at a certain
what if your ancestors were slave owners
do you
I don't know my family came over later
so don't look at me because Angela Davis
is descended from the Mayflower I love
this story but I mean it's like look a
lot of people on the right are like
Angela Davis she's like she's like a
black panther right she was yeah she
committed communist the Communist Party
in America was not radical enough for
her so she quit but like the the thing
is you know these people like y'all do
realize the reason she's descended from
people from the Mayflower is not because
she's like the heir to the Mayflower
family it's because the slave owners
probably raped her ancestors and like
had kids it wasn't like you know a
daughter in the Mayflower flower family
fell in love with a black man and they
decided to defy the law and
miscegenation and have kids it was
probably a slave woman being raped by a
slave owner or something like that so
it's like it's not like you know when
when people are making fun of her I'm
like ah it's kind of a bad thing but my
question then becomes she's still the
descendants of slave owners right
like how does that work well it doesn't
matter because they'll still claim that
well your skin color still made it so
that the social you know the the social
interactions you know you were still
discriminated against even though these
were your descendants but yeah it does
go back to that that community of of
victimhood and you could see it on her
face when she was told oh your ancestors
came on the Mayflower she was like oh no
this is too much like this is horrible
it's like you should probably get a get
a 23andMe or an ancestry.com before you
start making your entire career and your
entire personality predicated on the
idea that you were a victim to be fair
she was doing this in the 60s this was a
little before they they sequenced the
genome
um I just want to say that this is
probably Scott Adams approved
the reparations yeah because if black
people are gonna go like mad to San
Francisco
um Scott Adams said in that video where
they called him racist he said he was in
favor of affirmative action and
diversity programs and stuff like that
so it's just like they really did cut
the context of what she was saying
because it was like I support these
things like you know I I yeah but anyway
well the San Francisco one is crazy
because there are qualifications can't
just be anyone right so you have to have
been in the city between uh 1940 and
1996. or you have to be it have been
like 96 yeah if you've been if you were
born between 1940 and 1986 or wasn't
there for at least 13 years if you've
migrated there from a different country
between 1940 and 1996 you also like can
have been personally affected I'm not
sure I couldn't get an explanation out
of the document I read because they
proposed this a couple months ago and at
the time
this this program's gonna cost 50
billion dollars so what I think is crazy
is they're saying like a couple of the
other things like if you've been
affected by the War on Drugs you have
you meet one of the two uh of eight
criteria that need to I gotta compromise
take the 50 billion dollars from one of
these well big tech companies Facebook
or something take 50 billion 50 billion
from them and then give out reparations
I would I would accept those terms no it
will never end though they'll get
reparations and it's it's never ending
yeah I mean my point though is I don't
care it destroys Facebook yeah so you
know it's like whatever no this makes me
think okay oh no we got to get more
vibrations oh what's what's that Google
oh geez it's gonna have to take money
from you next oh what's that Pfizer but
maybe they should right because if
you're saying like uh Black Americans in
San Francisco have been
disproportionately affected by a lot of
things and they now can't afford housing
here well who drove up housing in San
Francisco San Francisco's already
expensive but tech industry did so maybe
Google and Facebook should contribute to
this fund yeah but what I think is crazy
is that they're saying like yeah we'll
say yes because they know they'll
possibly get elected off of it it's
never gonna happen there's no way they
have 50 billion dollars to fund this
program they're just going to say but
we're the ones who voted in favor of
reparation so elect me again I mean you
guys bring up interesting points but you
fail to consider what these Tech
Engineers will eat for lunch if they
give away all this money how will they
get their steak lunches how will they
get their wine untapped him that is true
come on I know that that keeps me up at
night sometimes we'll have to pay them
I'm imagining some 22 year old fresh out
of college you know crying because the
wine on tap stopped running
uh I think that really we shouldn't harm
the tech industry we should just Rob all
of Middle America to pay for San
Francisco's reparation program
yeah no I uh so you agree there's a lot
going on here sorry uh yeah no this
reminds me I went I did a man on the
street in San Francisco a couple months
back when they were doing their
reparations program quote unquote for
Trans people in San Francisco that said
if you're trans you were negatively
affected by the social ills and the
discrimination against transgenders and
so they were giving out money what was
it it was like thirteen hundred dollars
a month for up to 18 months you're
getting paid just to be you yeah the
weirdest thing about the reparations in
California is that California was never
a slave state yeah it's like I don't
understand what is California paying for
they're just
they are the most sorry
it's only like and it can't happen so if
you're a black American in San Francisco
who really thinks like maybe I will make
some money off of this like you're being
lied to and they're okay with that
because it scores them essentially cheap
political points
five million dollars per person I mean
if you could identify as trans can I
identify as black and move to San
Francisco yes you have to it's us here
you have to have identified as black or
African-American on public documents for
at least 10 years so like even if you're
white
Rachel dolezal is like I'm ready here we
go I mean hold on what if what if what
if she is ascended of slaves
you know what I mean like Angela Davis
is descendant of the is a descendant of
the Mayflower but pilgrims or whatever
or colonists or whatever
I feel like if anyone Rachel dolezal
might be descendant of uh Irish
indentured servants but I doubt that she
is affected by the slave trade but I'm
not saying necessarily her I'm saying
that there's going to be some white dude
with blonde hair and blue eyes who pulls
out as 23 in me and it's like 2.7
percent black and he's like yep there's
like you know old old great great great
great grandma and you know for sure
that's right first African-American I
cannot wait for Tariq nasheed's take on
this because you you do know about his
whole thing about the fba's the
foundational black Americans uh you know
trick Nasheed yeah so yeah he he's like
a black nationalist guy yeah yeah and he
rails against the non-fba so essentially
if you weren't a foundational black
American if you weren't some of the
first slaves then he gets mad at these
Africans and these other black people
that came over later or just recently
and they say that they're entitled to
these reparations
um and he goes hard on them so I'm
really I'm looking forward to his his
take on this racism is so profitable
races he's racist against other black
people he is so I got an idea because uh
people I'm not totally against this
point though
we're gonna do reparations I kind of get
what he's saying people are super
chatting about how they're working hard
and working in factories and all that
stuff here's my plan all right
you know in the future if I ever end up
finding myself in office I'll propose a
bill or maybe when I go talk to Matt
Gates I'll be back hey make this bill
that uh if you work in a non-labor job
you got to pay double the taxes and that
goes to the people who actually do work
there you go problem solved so like if
you work at a university well you know
we're going to take an extra you know 15
of your paycheck and it's going to go
pay a factory worker salary I like that
it's the least we could do to help the
workers right you don't oppose the
workers do you it's an only fans tax
right let's take let's take 30 out of
the only fans models and give them to
their stock Brokers pay Traders uh
universities professors feminists dance
theorists tax on all of that yeah
government bureaucrats and then anybody
who actually makes stuff they get a
bonus in their salary supplemental
income that's well that's socialism I
mean right they agree with it or maybe
we should just make everyone complete
two years of like a skill trade before
they can enter a four-year University
like maybe you should have to work with
your hands before you pursue your degree
I think every every gender studies
degree should have at least
they're forced to break rocks yeah
yeah or just Shadow like a plumber I
just love it there was a there was a
meme of some like leftist being like I
can't wait till we make them you know
break rocks so that they can figure out
what what a real day's uh real day of
hard work feels like and it's just like
you don't work what what are you talking
about who are you talking about the dude
who works in a factory driving a
forklift all day and is covering sweat
and the guy works on a petroleum rig
drenched in oil and high chance at Death
Do you ever see those uh videos on
Instagram or Tick Tock where it's like a
day in my life as a consultant I woke up
at 9 30 and I put on my sweatsuit and
then I went to my desk to start working
and like seemed perfectly Pleasant have
a good time but I really want like a
commercial electrician the electrician
to make one oh I woke up at 3am and
commuted to work and then you know I
wired and I had to cut all this stuff
like I carried got into an argument with
a client and it's like him filming a guy
yelling at him yeah it's just them going
to seven meetings a day what do you need
to go to a meeting for like do you think
Farmers like have meetings every morning
for three hours you think the guy in the
oil rig is like yeah I went to four
meetings today no he's like I'll Circle
back to it it's fine yeah look at how
many people Twitter fired in the past
six months oh man and Twitter
essentially operates the same and they
fired thousands of people now think
about that at every University in
America every big tech company every
startup everybody that could convince a
uh someone with some money that they
they'd give me money and I'll make your
money into a tech giant or whatever
um they that's they get funding and they
load it up with with all their friends
who are doing nothing at all you know
what you know what the oil rig doesn't
have they don't have yoga rooms you know
the oil rig doesn't have wine on tap you
know what the yoga room doesn't have or
it's in the yogurt oil rig yeah they
don't have the uh the what is it the
sensory deprivation room it's like God
the luxury of these these Tech Engineers
is ridiculous yeah let's jump to this uh
story here I saw this tweet and I'm just
I'm just assuming it's true I don't know
when it's it's posted today Florida
state senator what is this at Governor
gone wild who's this Blaze uh
ingoglia Florida Senator uh past
chairman of Florida GOP files a bill to
decertify by any political party whose
platform ever supported slavery the bill
is titled the ultimate cancel act mic
drop uh I agree
uh do you all in favor of I thought mic
drop was in the name of that all all in
favor of decertifying any political
party who ever supported slavery say aye
here here Tim hi hi all right well okay
let's go through the list of uh major
political parties and see which ones are
stricken we have Republicans uh they're
good and then we have Democrats and you
know they're they're out uh and uh
that's the list okay all right the green
party is like Here We Come This Is Us
everyone moves over that's a chance I I
agree with this bill actually 100 and it
should if they're gonna go tear down
statues then uh yeah let's get rid of
the Democratic Party
there we go I like that in most public
high schools in America they'll teach
you oh well actually it was Republicans
it's just that the parties change names
or some like they twist the logic so
intensely to make it be like well what
it couldn't be Democrats Democrats would
never I mean there are still people
alive today who are who are Democrats
and clan members but you know that's
besides the point
no no they don't acknowledge still alive
today yeah yeah
how long ago was it where uh uh I mean
this was like the 60s 70s I mean there's
the clan still exists yes many of these
people probably are no longer democrats
for sure I mean but you'd be surprised
there there have been white nationalists
have come out and talked about how the
Democratic platform is good and then
they explain all the things that
typically Republicans complain about
like like the Democrats destroying the
black family and things like that so
yeah do you get it didn't Richard
Spencer endorse yeah Richard Spencer's a
big biting guy right now yeah he was too
I think in uh 2020 he was for by not
Trump yeah he says because Trump didn't
do the things they thought he was going
to do he wasn't that guy anybody that's
for physical removal is got there
there's got to be a big government to go
along to do the removing like anybody
that's talked like Spencer was used to
be Pro you know removing people and
stuff he likes Authority yeah so does
the Democratic party yeah you you don't
get it I'm just look I don't know about
all that I'm just saying antifa went
around and BLM went around tearing down
statues that uh not even like they tore
on a statue of Hans Christian Hague who
was an abolitionist who died fighting to
free slaves
so okay I guess whatever I don't know
what they're but if if they're all about
this then I I think they'd agree with us
right we can you know get antifa get on
board with this bill and we'll get rid
of the democratic party this is such a
power play I love it because then
Democrats will have to say no no like I
want to see how many other states
or five other state legislators pick it
up and get some momentum gotta make some
phone calls to West Virginia yeah
seriously yeah we'll talk to uh we're
gonna be I think the plan is to be at
Congress again this Friday big old
congress party yeah I'm not going to say
too much but I think we're gonna be
there I'll I'll make sure to bring this
up to all of them like hey you guys want
to do the condemning slavery act or
something like that and then it's to
publicly denounce and reject any
political party that's ever supported
slavery we'll start making picket signs
as soon as the show's over yeah I'm
excited yeah it's the ultimate cancel
act so it's perfect yeah the ultimate
new magic coming out against this act
Ryan do is amend it to be like
recognizing the failures of America Act
or something like that and then what
they'll do is they'll be like it's not
the Democratic party it's all America
and the Republicans have to counter and
be like actually we're the ones who
wanted to get rid of the slavery so you
know sorry remember that whole War thing
yeah that was you guys and you know uh
just trying to change your name doesn't
doesn't change anything not only that
but like people always rag on The Young
Turks because their name is like The
Young Turks which was a genocidal group
of people and you know it's like imagine
naming your media organization the
Hitler Youth is basically what The Young
Turks did but like think about the
Democratic party then like the
Democratic party is the organization
that that represented slavers and
slavery if you're going to be critical
of The Young Turks that you certainly
got to be critical of of the democratic
party title right fine with me and they
can't really like pull a Washington
Redskins slash what are they the
commanders now like it's not like they
can be like well now we're the and their
mascots now we're the Confederates
I love that the mascot for the
Washington commanders is a pig yeah
who is
who is that under like wow
oh there's so
many or they just just completely there
is a Savvy meme Lord who worked for that
company and was like this is going to be
the greatest thing this is the most
hilarious thing
yeah I get apparently there's uh there's
something about there were players that
were called the hogs in the 80s the
offensive line or something like that
and so that's how the the pigs are
associated with the uh Washington
it's a big stretch and you'd think that
someone would be like oh why do we want
to go ahead and call the Washington team
you know with the seat of power is and
at least be like a horse right that's
like what Commander's Road during the
war think like I I just don't understand
I mean it has to be on purpose that they
made this decision like you can't like
file papers in these companies these big
companies without there being oversight
and I know that there's a video out
there of some board member or some like
employee that's in the corner like
filming the discussion they had and I
need to see it I love it I just can't
imagine
I feel like the best part of this bill
is that it's here the sad part is that I
don't think that it will survive like
unfortunately I don't think it'll pass
if it does I'd be happy to be wrong on
this one I think sometimes one of the
coolest things about State Legislature
is state legislators is that they just
introduce things to prove a point right
they say like even though I know this
won't make it out of committee I think
that we should talk about the fact that
we haven't condemned this Congress
passed the Congress passed the
anti-lynching bill like just last year
and that is literally just for show yeah
just to you know prove a point so it's
not just a state decades after they
probably should have right yeah it
wasn't anything I mean with State I
think it's more interesting because then
you have the conversation right like if
even if Florida doesn't pass this we all
recognize that perhaps we should condemn
parties that had slaveries as part of
their platform
yeah we should provide funding to
parties that oppose it
guaranteed the green party is like here
we go I'm ready well I don't know when
is the Green Party founded I don't think
they've been around post slavery so
they've never had it in their platform
that's fair point Democrats are just in
trouble they're uh they're a relic of a
bygone era Libertarians are excited yeah
yeah they've been around for a long time
right they've been around since the 70s
and they have always been opposed to
slavery oh yes keep confidently say that
I can very confidently I can't say it if
you're a Democrat the libertarian party
has always been opposed to slavery they
should uh make the bill the um rejecting
political parties that support slavery
and supporting political parties that
don't act yeah and just being like that
leaves you Democrats green party you're
all right Republicans Libertarians
Reform Party man look at this huge list
of Working Families party they're good
Democrats no you're on the No-No list
the Tea Party will rise again yeah here
they come it would be kind of
interesting though if like there
couldn't be a Democratic party would
they just Rebrand Allah
whoever or would you get enough like
people bleeding out to have different
different factions of the party they
would quickly consolidate around a
person that has decided what the new
party probably Barack Obama
it would be like someone someone like
Barack Obama that would say okay you're
on the kakim's referees is like yes we
can need to destroy this party so I can
rise to the top I don't think that it'll
even get to the point where a pat where
it would pass in the U.S but I but I I
imagined the circumstances would be they
would they would coalesce around a
person that comes up with a name for the
new party and and they would you know
reluctantly leave the Democrat the DNC
but all the same people would go over
because you're not getting rid of any
ideas you're just getting rid of a name
I suppose in the longer run if you can
if you can suppress ideas then you will
eventually eliminate them from the from
the psyche from the population and
that's the purpose of all the censorship
they're engaging in that's that's the
idea I think that the the whole
um if you don't have the words to uh
articulate a thought then you can't
think the wrong things I'd like the the
whole 1984 justification for Newspeak
that is something that's legit in
practice nowadays the reason that the
lgbtq uh political Lobby demands that
you uh say that a trans woman is a woman
is because they're demanding that you
conceptualize a trans woman and a
biological woman as the same they're
making a demand on your cognitive
Liberty and they're they're doing it by
messing with the the language that we
use with the meanings of words right
this is what they did on the LA the last
Twitter board or the last Twitter
um you know people they they were
Banning the word groomer to call out
predatory adults who were grooming
children and if you ban the words then
like you said you're Banning their their
cognitive ability to make assumptions
and uh accurately assess people's
behavior
yeah so it kind of feels like
everything's falling apart a little bit
you know but uh it's okay because we
have chickens they're out doing their
thing and they give us eggs and one of
the chickens is brooding uh one of the
silkies so what we do now is we're going
to take a bunch of eggs from all the
different chickens and put them
underneath the Broody silky which will
then hatch a variety like like a a a
plethora of chicken varieties so when it
all comes crashing down and you find
yourself in a city fighting Agnes over
the last can of beans in the in front of
the bodega I'm gonna be sitting there
with Roberto Jr enjoying some fresh
scrambled eggs see I don't mind some
turbulence right like I think having
these issues in front of us makes us
talk about them I think that was one of
the mistakes that some conservatives had
for a while which is to say Live and Let
Live which I agree with for the most
part but you can also say I disagree I
don't believe in that and I think for so
long sort of out of politeness we were
saying like oh just everyone will just
keep to themselves and we won't address
things and then you get to the point
where it gets so out of control that
you're asked like do you think it's okay
for a teacher to tell a child that
they're transgender and then not tell
the parents like we have to be willing
to have the hard conversations and
especially if they're if the uh the
opposition to these two two hard ideas
says basically well to avoid that we'll
take down monuments and we'll we'll edit
books and we'll change things so that we
can just avoid these conversations it
makes us a weaker Society if we can't
deal with this kind of uh disagreement I
think that this speaks to the to
um
Matt Walsh's point and and to Tim's
point when he says that uh we need to be
mean
um I don't think that maybe mean isn't
the the best word but uh
pulling back from being
Frank when we describe things it's it's
detrimental to the to people's ability
to understand what we're talking about
yeah you got to push it more than you
normally would I guess you don't you if
you've you've given up ground to
progressives we get up so so much ground
that now taught that now children are
literally being targeted for ideological
you know
um
you unplugged the UFO oh no it's okay I
took out the UFO when I sit on that side
table Yeah but there's also an an
empathy a true empathy for calling
things the way they are there's no
niceness about calling you know these
body positive people healthy when it's
not there's no positivity and there's no
empathy in saying that these trans
people that are mutilating themselves
are healthy because that is not leading
them down fulfilled lives that is
destroying them and that's also the
importance of we need to build our own
things if we're going to actually combat
the woke left we can't just be reacting
to them and we can't just be tearing
them down there is an importance to it
because they have left and they've
planted seeds and they have gone down
and they have strong roots but we also
need to plant our own seeds like I said
if we want to combat this body body
positivity movement you need to go to
the gym right if we want to combat the
taking down of statues we need to make
our own if we go on to combat the woke
left gender ideology we need to make our
own schools we need to homeschool and if
we want to combat the end of the world
then we gotta make our own chicken coops
right Tim
absolutely let me pull up this story
here I was uh reading from the NBC News
Mississippi Governor signs Bill Banning
transgender health care for minors to
see how NBC News frames it let's try
another wipe Let's uh I'll give you a
different headline Mississippi Governor
signs Bill Banning child genital
mutilation miners cannot consent
like huh it says in the name children if
they're children they're minors they
can't consent they're not they cannot
well the issue is the parents can
because the parents consent to it
so here's what it says
Mississippi on Tuesday begin the seventh
state to enact a restriction on certain
transition related health care for
minors Governor Tate Reeves Republican
said he signed the bill which bars
puberty blockers hormone therapy and
surgery for minors because there is a
dangerous movement spreading across
America today it's advancing under the
guise of a false ideology and
pseudoscience is being pushed onto our
children through radical activists
social media and online influencers and
it's trying to convince our children
that they are in the wrong body this
dangerous movement attempts to convince
these children that they're just a
surgery away from happiness it threatens
our children's innocence and it
threatens their health
it's crazy he invited Matt Walsh from
the daily wire to speak
and the crazy thing is I was talking to
Ali London last week on the culture War
podcast and uh he was saying that he
thought the surgery would make him happy
and he kept getting different plastic
surgeries wondering when he would
finally feel happy and it wasn't working
because the issue isn't the surgery
but the thing is for for Ali I think he
only really got the facial cosmetic
stuff done so many of these young girls
and uh young males have permanently
removed healthy organs they will not be
able to ever have they'll never have
them again and so this is permanently
sterilized some of these kids like jazz
Jennings and Kim Petras will never have
children never have children billions of
years of evolution ends right there with
those individuals and you know what that
three-year-old Jazz did not know that
seven-year-old Jazz did not know that
and I wonder if there's going to come a
point in the lives of these these these
poor people when they're in their 20s
thinking how do I have kids and it's
like well we removed that from you
because you are seven and you said you
wanted it removed
seven years old and then at 17 both I
believe Patrick's may have been 16 and
Jazz was 17. they have both been 17 but
those are miners these are under the age
of majority were given genital removal
what do you call it um
testicular ectomy or something like that
the surge of castration but like there's
like there's got to be an ectomy word
for it right like a hysterectomy the
other hysterectomy yeah like women have
hysterectomies and bilateral
ovarectomies or something like the
ovarectomies or whatever you know
ovarian removal yeah I mean this it's
just we need to stop you know the whole
phrase right now is stop trans and kids
I think we need to stop transiting
people in general but it starts with
kids I think a society is judged on how
they treat their most innocent and there
are many things in our society that we
deem inappropriate or harmful to
children that regardless of the parents
intent regardless of the parents wishes
we don't allow them to engage in right
we don't give them alcohol just because
the parent says that this is acceptable
or that my child identifies as an adult
and therefore I can give them alcohol we
don't allow kids to be shown pornography
or to even go to R-rated movies or to
download these R-rated video games but
for some some reason under the guise of
this lgbtq movement under the guise of
gender affirming care or the pride flag
we are allowing them to chemically
castrate themselves and it's it is
leaving them sad it is leaving them
deformed and ultimately they're not
better off they're they're told they're
lied to and said that you will be happy
um and that you're not going to regret
this and it's killing kids they're gonna
they're gonna wake up like you said when
they're 20 30 years old themselves why
did this doctor tell me that I would be
happy why did my parents go along with
this who was there to protect me and as
a society we need to we need to be those
people to protect them despite their
wishes it's crazy I feel like you know
we know we know the history of certain
medications like was it thalidomide was
that the name of the drug thalidomide it
was like an anti-nausea medicine they
gave to mothers and the kids were born
with like no arms and their hands were
just like on their shoulders or whatever
all kinds of terrible defects and then
you you get a generation of people that
have you know that have to live this way
we're getting the same thing here I mean
people have said it's going to be not
too dissimilar to lobotomies the removal
of healthy organs and and their the
targeting of minors hey look you're an
adult and you want to make a decision
for yourself
ain't nobody there but you and God and
you know a a functioning Society should
do their best to to help and protect you
in the best way possible if you're a
child there is a bigger challenge that
we were just bringing up do the parents
have the right to consent to what
medical treatment they think would save
their kids life the question then
becomes how you have to actively Define
when something is legitimately going to
save a child's life challenge is there I
mean we used to drink Mercury I'm sure a
lot of Medical Treatments we have today
that are legitimate May some point be
like oh that drug actually was bad it
was causing these problems so there's a
difficulty in navigating this because we
want to talk about parental rights like
in Florida what if a parent wants to get
their kid castrated does the government
then intervene and say no hold on what
if a parent wants to get their kid some
kind of treatment say you know some kind
of experimental medication that could
cure some genetic disorder and the
government says no does the parent have
the right to choose and like what are
those limits
if there's a legitimate role for
government I think protecting innocent
life is among the legitimate rules and I
think that that at some point that has
probably going to end up being arbitrary
but at some point we have to decide this
is where the state steps in
um
and I don't know where that point is and
the problem is you've got powerful
political factions in half the country
that believe the state should step in to
castrate the kid yes well because they
put a clock on it right so they want to
have you make the decision when your kid
is prepubescent because theoretically
going through puberty is traumatic for a
kid who feels as though they are in the
wrong body right I don't believe that I
personally don't believe this but this
is an argument that comes up for parents
right if you if you have a daughter and
your daughter identifies as a boy
getting her period would be traumatic
because she doesn't feel like she should
have it it's it's a it makes any kind of
gender dysphoria worse and that kind of
urgency and pressure is
terrible right no one makes there are
some people who make good decisions
Under Pressure but I don't think anyone
can make a good decision when he's like
how do I keep my kid from being
traumatized especially when actually you
don't know what the alternatives are
there are no Alternatives being pushed
on you it's being pushed on you uh I
think that's crazy personally I think it
comes I think of it similar to should
you be allowed to get a nose job when
you're 16 right personally I feel like
if you're a good parent you would say no
wait until you're an adult wait until
you're older I can make it but it knows
job doesn't sterilize you but I don't
think but it's permanent right you can't
put it back it doesn't sterilize you but
you can't then say I want my original no
yeah but like not being able to have
kids we should be encouraging children
to make decisions like these
life-changing decisions should be made
when they themselves are adults I don't
think that because your parents can
consent to you getting a nose job at 16
means that the child should anytime you
have to go under uh anesthesia and
actually be put out like that's there's
a risk to it I mean they are fairly
routine but there's a risk to it so if
it's not something necessary I think
maybe the government should say look
don't do this to kids until they're 18.
be just because of the risk of going you
know complications from surgery they're
real doesn't happen a lot but they are
real so again if there is a legitimate
role for government
um then protecting innocent life has to
be among it you know protecting the
borders protecting innocent life give
you courts and and that's about it but
it's easy it's easy to say but then what
about a medical treatment a parent wants
to get for their kid the government
won't allow
right so that
that the challenges it is not about the
law it is about the cultural values and
the left values child sex changes and
the right doesn't but there may come a
time where there's something the right
says like hey we need to give this kid
this medication for like I don't know
spinal meningitis something and if you
empower the government they could be
like nope and then you're sitting there
being like excuse me like my kid's gonna
die get him to stream like we're not
going to do it well in a lot of these
laws that get written in saying you
can't offer hormone therapy or whatever
else they have exceptions for kids who
are legitimately legitimately born
intersex right when they have X X Y
chromosomes or whatever I think for me
as a society it would be nice and I feel
like this is unrealistic if we could all
agree that ultimately any kind of
permanent surgery should be the decision
of someone who is in full possession of
their rights so I mentioned this before
most minors aren't in full possession of
the rights because they are under the
custody of their parents and so
therefore we shouldn't be leaving it up
to their parents to decide what happens
to you there about it they have to be an
adult with full possession have their
rights to be able to consent to any of
these surgeries
I mean I I just think it's not even
about
it's not even about the child choosing
or the parents choosing it is literally
just about our moral values period my
moral values are you don't give kids sex
changes have a nice day I'm not going to
I don't need to create any kind of weird
philosophical or or moral-based it's
like or or a legal basis for it where
it's like well the government shouldn't
be no no no no don't care sometimes the
government should sometimes they
shouldn't this is a case where they
shouldn't the left believes that the
government should make this stuff happen
and the parents should get a right to
choose I think that's crazy I think the
parents should also not be allowed to
choose in this circumstance I do not
believe parents have a right to choose
their children get their sex organs
removed that's just me but there are
certain circumstances where I think the
parents should have a right to choose
certain Medical Treatments for their
kids it is not a black and white
argument there is no simple answer of do
the parents have rights or do they not
it's not that simple the parents should
have rights in some circumstances and
not in others if the parents want to
think that you know making their baby
vegan is going to be good for them the
government should be like yeah it's
stupid you don't do that your baby will
die you can't you can't have vegan maybe
I mean you maybe can it's like really
really difficult but you probably
probably give your kid proper nutrition
or something like that government should
intervene where we deem it culturally
and morally pertinent the left has
different moral standards which we view
as demonic and that is a very serious
problem for our society because you've
got mothers and fathers who are like I
have three kids we're all trans I'm like
come on man
it is it is it is statistically
anomalous that a child is Trans in the
first place but for a parent to have
three and we see these stories that
means called CPS well and the government
does regulate it under some
circumstances right like you'll see all
these articles about especially women in
their early 20s being like I wanted to
get a hysterectomy and my doctor
wouldn't let me because they kept saying
what if you change your mind and this is
terrible I mean why is it that under
that circumstance the government is like
no you can't get a hysterectomy and when
it's about gender identity it's like
well okay you're 18. it's a good idea
like it seems bizarre to me as a double
standard maybe we just shouldn't cut out
organs that were there in the first
place unless it is absolutely medically
necessary because it makes they're
arguing it is necessary I know with like
and so the issue is the issue it's not
about it's about where we culturally
draw the line period the doctors are
going to come and be like if we don't do
it they'll kill themselves and it's like
okay well that means they're no an
immediate risk of death right now right
okay so we can not do it and then just
give them therapy and watch them and
make sure they don't it's not like they
have a sack of pus and abscess or
something and they're gonna die like
appendicitis we got breaking news though
real quick on this one just a real quick
announcement Lori Lightfoot it's out she
lost Beetlejuice is gone no more Lori
Lightfoot in Chicago Paul vallis and
Brandon Johnson are going to advance to
run off apparently so uh there you go
that's it Lori lightfold at Lightfoot
and she did really bad she got she got
60 16 then the next guy got 20 and the
next I got 35. that's just oof the other
day she said it's because she's a black
woman that people won't vote for her
that's how she Justified being in third
she said that yeah yeah they voted for
the first time it didn't make sense to
me either I'm just saying that's what
she suggested all right all right we're
gonna go to super chats I wonder who
summoned her you know we're gonna how do
you put her back yeah well she's gone so
I'm glad you know that's that's good
maybe I'll go visit Chicago at some
point if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com go to timbs.com click join
us and at about 10 10 we're going to
have a Live members only show it is not
family friendly it is uncensored and uh
you put you put your kids to bed they
don't want to hear this stuff but it'll
be live and we can take some comments
for now because there's a comment
function on the website but we are
currently building out the Discord so
you can chat 24 7. chat during the
members only show and during this show
as well as well as potential call-ins in
the uncensored show so again smash the
like button let's read we got I'm not
your buddy guy says
does it surprise anyone really leftist
rhetoric is on par with Germany 1936.
even Trudeau said that the truckers uh
that we were taking up space
technically he said it before the Convoy
but it was about us who supported the
Convoy and our freedom
I mean
if you live in Canada you're basically
living in dictatorship so I don't know
what to tell you
got to get out of Canada somehow
flooded timber Farm says can y'all
confirm if Vanguard took away their one
trillion dollar investment from ESG saw
something on Twitter about it no idea I
don't know if you guys see anything
about that no no idea no idea all right
where are we at Tim Brackett says don't
let them divide us build culture based
on love truth and freedom that's what
we're doing baby the coffee shop is is
being put together as we speak and it
just takes time these projects take a
long time especially because I I don't
spearhead them I just like delegate the
task to somebody else
uh if the only thing I was doing with my
life was opening coffee shop then it
would be open already but uh I can only
do so much when I'm doing everything
else and but we want to have the space
and uh we're going to be launching a
show that I'm really excited about
called poker with the boys and it's
going to be just kind of like a hangout
podcast with poker as a backdrop because
uh it's fun and we had a Clint from
liberty lockdown podcast who was saying
he used to be a pro poker player and I
was like dude imagine if we're hanging
out beers nachos talking about whatever
we feel like talking about for the week
and then the basis of the show is kind
of like we're here to play a game and
people are just goofing off I think it
would be a lot of fun Clinton poso can
hug it out yeah yeah that'd be funny and
then uh you know just poker as a
backdrop a way to get a bunch of people
sitting around a table all snapping
jokes at each other people can start
talking about stuff and I think it'll be
a lot of fun if if you hear the con
anybody who's ever played knows the
conversations are hilarious when you're
ragging on each other and stuff it can
be a lot of fun so building culture is
what it's all about and we also got a
couple other shows in the pipeline that
I'm really excited about so stick around
stick around all right Raymond g Stanley
Jr says geez Louise Tim I'm listening at
work do you read the account the brother
told of his sister dropping dead in
their dad's arms thinking of my siblings
I got teary-eyed what the heck is
happening
20 uh what's your 20 year old woman
wakes up in the morning in London
or in the UK and she uh sees her dad and
her dad asked her if she wants coffee
and she says no tea he makes her tea
hands of the glass then all sudden she
puts it down so it's feeling her chest
she says my chest hurts
and then she dies and he catches her and
then he's on the ground doing CPR
desperately trying to save his daughter
who just died suddenly and the
paramedics come in and they bring her
out and uh
they get to the hospital they say she's
not breathing and then moments later
they say she's dead geez yeah I wonder
what's causing it all well there's a new
report out that says erythritol is
causing uh blood clots strokes and heart
attacks yeah it's all these keto diet
stuff yep all these people are doing the
keto diet they're having erythritol and
that's what that's they they say that's
what's causing it so
you know all right well you know POS
violations that's that's all I wanted
we'll go to the members only segment at
timcast.com become a member and we'll
talk more in a little bit all right
let's see we got Jackhammer says go
ahead Tim get involved you'll go to
prison that's in reference to uh this is
actually before uh Phil brought it up
this is in reference to the guy getting
killed in St Louis if you intervene
they're gonna lock you up
so what do you do that's crazy though
man like a dude raped a woman on a train
in front of a bunch of other people and
they just watched that seems crazy to me
I'm I'm watching 1883 and a guy
pickpockets a guy and the whole town
beats the crap out of him puts a rope
around his neck and just Yanks him up
and kills him and I'm like jeez there's
like a scene where they walk into a
saloon and the sheriff is like Billy Bob
and he's like which one was it and then
he points at the guys and he starts
shooting him and I'm like back in the
day I don't know if you call that
justice but they just did not care
yikes nowadays the criminals get let out
of prison keep doing it
all right
cam girl as soon as it's worse than
simply people not caring to help him
anyone who helps will be destroyed for
it they will lose jobs reputation to go
to prison all while the criminal goes
free with no penalty I want you to
Imagine This
dude in St Louis pulls out a gun and
starts trying to chamber around
something's wrong with it he's shaking
it and so then you see that and you see
these guys fighting you're like I know
this is going so you run up and you
tackle the guy and then the guy filming
comes out and he's holding the camera
going I'm filming everything I'm filming
everything
then in the scuffle the guy with the gun
gets shot
guess what the story is then George
Floyd 2.0 uh Ahmed Aubry 2.0 yeah white
white supremacist violently assaults
black man for no reason on the street
kills him and then you're gonna go to
prison for the rest of your life crazy
huh
that's the way it's been going
that's the way it's been going man
yikes
all right Thomas sidebottom says noticed
with regards to the lead story that very
few very few news outlets called the
victim homeless it was mostly unhoused
or without a home
that's right unhoused that's just a
homeless which is an AP style guide It's
just so it's so dumb George Carlin had
the best he was like we keep changing
language because people are so offended
you know post who he was like they make
it longer used to be called shell shock
now it's post-traumatic stress disorder
yeah
they just keep making it longer all
right where are we at battle fatigue
battle fatigue yeah yeah
Anthony Campbell says the St Louis
prosecutor Kim Gardner is currently in
legal trouble with Missouri due to her
inaction on Prosecuting criminals it's
been a big story here in the past week
or so
yup because these Soros D.A people are
like I don't want anyone going to jail
probably because they want anarcho
tyranny clearly
and then it all comes falling apart
Jimbo says I'm a field technician
constantly traveling to my accounts my
employer doesn't allow concealed carry
and it really irks me I understand but I
don't agree I really need to self-employ
agreed you do
all right it totally against the law if
you get caught yeah
John L says there is no way I could not
intervene in an overt act like this I
was raised to protect myself my family
and those who can't jail be damned
perhaps and then you'll find yourself in
jail
quite uh simply put it's crazy the Ahmed
Arbury story is a really great example
of two guys who were trying to protect
their neighborhood were attacked and now
they're in prison for the rest of their
lives yeah I'm gonna make sure I say
that again for all the Media Matters
leftists and The Young Turks the
McMichaels Got a notification from
police about a man who was committed
committing felony burglaries or
suspected of it there's a video of Ahmed
Aubry committing felony burglary or at
least there's a video of a man they
believe zombie doing it the police went
to the McMichael's home and said here's
the guy then someone was like hey look
that's the guy so they said let's stop
him they wanted him arrested they were
told not to do it fair point and then
Ahmed Arbury clearly on camera runs
towards the McMichaels runs around the
truck and starts fighting over the
shotgun and gets shot in the scuffle
so imagine you live in a neighborhood
where a gun has been stolen for months
someone's been burglarizing homes and
then the cops are like we think it's
this guy and you see the guy and you're
like better do nothing and let him keep
robbing the the neighbors and doing
doing who knows what with that gun
because uh you will go to prison for the
rest of your life if you even film it
that's the message they sent the guy who
filmed it happening and did nothing else
is spending the rest of his life in
prison in the unmanned Arbor case yeah
the guy that was the guy a guy got in
his car because he saw the McMichaels
jump in their car so he started filming
them he then slowly followed Ahmed Aubry
filming him because this is the suspect
who was seen on camera burglarizing a
home yeah and then they were like I can
go to prison too I have more about that
about the I'm at Arbury story that I'll
tell you in the members section I'm not
going to say it in the free thing but I
I have a and all the conservatives came
out being like see Justice was served
Kyle rittenoff was innocent but the
McMichaels were guilty and I'm like did
any of you pay attention to what that
story was about totally no because they
can't touch it because they're afraid of
being accused of anything I mean they're
to be honest takes a little bit of
integrity and I think so many people who
say they're conservative and whatever
are afraid to be attacked in any way
because they know they can't ultimately
handle it I think it's because in the
Kyle Rittenhouse case the three people
who died weren't black and the Ahmed
Arbury case it was a high profile
unarmed black man who ended up dying I
would argue that that was a narrative he
wasn't unarmed the moment he touched the
shotgun he instantly became an armed
individual so there's there's an
argument there and I bring something up
so so often because it's such a travesty
of Justice like
I don't know man
if this guy was innocent and you see a
car behind you in a car in front of you
and a guy jumps out of the shotgun like
what would you do
but here's the issue Ahmed Arbury is a
suspect and a felony burglary and he was
seen in someone's house so I kind of
feel like in this instance with the
testimony from the police the statements
we heard from everybody to me it's
beyond a reasonable doubt this guy was
committing burglary and they were just
trying to stop him yeah nobody said he
was jogging and white supremacists
lynched him like think about how stupid
that story is that Ahmed Arbury was out
for a hike 20 miles from his home
wearing work boots and uh just is on
camera inside someone's house for no
reason because he was just looking
around that's what the left said and
then these uh White supremacists decided
that they were going to kill him and so
they just jumped in a vehicle and
decided to do that I'm like yeah that's
the stupidest fake story I've ever heard
but there's also like a hierarchy to
when you'll intervene because I get what
you're saying about integrity but you
have a duty first to be there for your
family and you know like it's all it's
not worth it at a certain point to it's
not worth it at a certain point to like
put yourself out there and what you
might go to jail and then you can't be
with your kids and your family for like
10 years
so I'm saying like if you're a news
media figure and you know a story as
being spun if you're afraid to comment
on it even though you know the narrative
is being Twisted no no I get like
personal safety and I understand like
with the the man on the street Street
who was shot like it is crazy to me that
someone could sit there with a cell
phone like they know something's going
on enough to pull out their phone and
start recording like at that time why
not call the police why not intervene in
some other way but for me it's like when
you know the narrative is being Twisted
to make some people look bad and you
aren't willing to at least say hey let's
re-examine this then you are not acting
with it the crazy the crazy thing to me
is that the dude's pulling out a gun and
he's like he's putting a magazine in it
right now and I'm just like maybe you
should get me you should not narrate
this no no maybe you should get away
from the guy if you're really concerned
like why are you sitting up against the
window filming it happen like either do
something or run I just it's crazy to me
it's like wow look at that guy they're
fighting and now he's pulling out a gun
I'm gonna I'm just gonna sit here this
is oh no oh whoa he killed him I can't
believe that happened were they fighting
prior to the some kind of argument yep
all right Jesse Vargas says I was hoping
you'd consider inviting Ryan Dawson on
the show sometime in my opinion nobody
even comes close in regards to honesty
integrity and Reporting throughout the
Decades of exposing our bloodthirsty
government and geopolitics all right
sounds interesting you know we got to
find guests for the Friday show we got a
good lineup these next several weeks
it's only going to get better
all right son of a Murph says Kentucky
is trying to pass a bill to allow
Farmers to sell right to Consumers
they can't yeah
what why would you need a bill to allow
you to do that in a ostensibly free
country we go to we go to the farm this
Farm's out here all the time we just
pull up and then you buy your meat right
from the farm some states might have
Revelations to prevent like foodborne
illness ostensibly I'm not saying it
should but yeah there's there's
regulations against buying unpasteurized
milk I remember we couldn't do that in
my own state of Michigan for a while so
for a little bit we ended up doing like
under the table deals and then we had to
work around it by buying the actual cow
on paper so that we get the milk from
the cow
but it's crazy the Hoops you got to jump
through to buy raw milk out here it's
called pet milk ah yep I like that so
you can buy pet milk your animal's
allowed to drink it you're not
but you can drink it
BH God uh Godsmack says one 1.99 for
Bill Gates voice mimic when you talk as
Gates all right the next time I talk is
Bill Gates I'll do the Bill Gates voice
although it's not really Bill Gates's
voice it's more of a Family Guy's
mockery of Bill Gates Family Guy is that
episode where Peter's hanging out with
like Michael Eisner Carter pewter
Schmidt and Bill Gates and then they're
like they're flying in a plane or
something and then someone's uh Peter
someone someone says like look at the
people they look like ants and then Bill
Gates goes they are ants I like the joke
when they're driving through a toll
booth and then Peter's like oh crap
anybody got a quarter and Bill Gates
goes what's a quarter
Family Guy oh yeah they're funny
all right what do we got
jdw jc11 says teach LGBT and CRT in
schools kids grow up uneducated bring in
H-1B visa workers Brown America goal of
the left I think it's more of the
destruction of American culture to seize
power I don't think the color has
anything to do with it they'll take
whatever they can get but um there was
something I saw on Twitter where they
said that college students were
struggling to break down sentence
structure yeah they didn't know what a
subject or a verb was
but they can tell you all about George
Floyd and other garbled nonsense
abolished the Department of Education it
is an entirely uh it is an entire
failure abolish it get rid of it well
and they recently did like this this
poll or This research in uh Chicago
public schools and there wasn't a single
child that could read at their grade
reading level a ball not one abolish the
doe it's a total failure get rid of it
Pat Delaney says hey Tim any chance you
need a full-time plumber need out of
Massachusetts worth a shot
I don't know about a full-time plumber
but we could use like somebody who does
a job that is a plumber on the side in
the event something happens I'll tell
you guys a real funny story
you see we're out in the middle of
nowhere and you know what that means be
not in the middle of nowhere do you guys
know what it means when you're middle
nowhere what's it in reference to
Plumbing
outhouses septic systems septic systems
and that means the city Folk show up
ignorant as ignorant gets start flushing
all sorts of knickknacks and who sits
down the toilet because in the city they
don't care and then out here what ends
up happening is you get septic backup
and it comes out of the ground and it
comes out of your pipes and into your
basement so we had um somebody was
pouring grease down the drain and you
know look in cities you you can get away
with it because all you're doing is
destroying the environment and the
plumbing of the city you might Gunk up
your pipes and have to get them replaced
but the damage often is being done to
the city you know when you have a septic
system and you pour bacon grease down
the drain I gotta tell you man
yeah so apparently one day in the
basement there's uh water starts pouring
out all sorts of places because this is
some backs up and so there's nothing you
can do what starts happening just tell
everyone to turn the water off no one
can use water and then by the time the
septic guys actually get there and start
clearing it out you've already got water
damage you've got fans turned on you're
trying to soak everything up and it's
septic back up if you know what I mean
so this happened and then the deceptic
guys came out and they had to like get a
big stick and stick into the pipe and
then what happened was they loosened it
up and like a 10 foot tube of bacon
grease came out like a hot dog like a
like a foot wide hot dog and slapped
into the septic system and uh we then
have to go through the security cameras
to figure out who is breaking the rules
and flushing this stuff and dumping the
stuff and uh we yep I'll just leave it
there yep
it's crazy because even after we were
like guys you cannot flush stuff down a
septic system it happens again this is
the crazy thing about humans because
it's like you know I don't know how many
people work directly in this building
but even after telling every single
person don't do it if there's always one
person who's like it's not my fault I'm
a snowflake not the Avalanche and it's
like dude all of you doing this thinking
you're fine oh man
well so yeah maybe we'll need a plumber
consider we're gonna have multiple uh
buildings
but I don't know what to tell you I
don't know probably just a contractor
plumber when we need it it would be
great if someone was here who could take
care of it before any problems happen
but you know whatever
Frey Kane says Tim says lifting Freight
as I work a 12-hour Factory job filling
pallets
yeah man
nazc says it's hilarious listening to
Tim talking about working class people
listening to him while I'm working at a
shop doing tires on 150k electric car
that has a Bernie stick around at home
man
jeez and then and then the guy the
Bernie supporter with his Ray-Ban sits
down and says I'm doing it for you and
then turns on the Tesla goes you know
the Tesla's make that sound right when
you turn them on they go like for I
think it's on purpose
they sound like ghosts but I think
that's a fake sound it is yeah
programmed yeah it's a program to noise
and you can actually change it to be an
engine yeah yes the Jetson sound right
you can probably change it yeah you can
you can press a button to make it fart
our guitar player Jason Richardson has a
Tesla and he makes a fart all the time I
can I can take my phone right now and
start yelling and the car will start
yelling and the weird thing about it is
it changes your voice like you can
remote security into your car and then
press the walkie-talkie button and say
Hey you get away from my car but instead
of it just playing the sound it'll go
hey you'll be away from my car and it's
just like okay it's just Phil's voices
yeah voice yelling yeah something like
that
I'm like I could just play the voice it
was funny we had the dogs running
outside and then we were using it and
yelling and the dogs were looking at the
car like what's happening it knows my
name yeah
all right
oh says most small farms or are organic
pasture-raised grass-fed Etc but they
can't they can't afford the tax to get
it labeled as such yeah exactly we go to
the local farm and it's like we would
like some beef and they give you like a
little bag full of beef and it's got
like the farm label on it and you know
it's grass-fed organic they just can't
legally call it that so they're like all
of our cows just eat grass and we don't
use any chemicals or anything like that
so you know but we can't call it organic
and grass-fed so you know because we
can't afford the tax like that's the
craziest part it's like 70 bucks to get
it labeled or something geez yeah
all right where are we at Thomas side
bottom says using different pronouns is
like deciding one day that you will
indicate you want to turn left while
driving by turning on the hazard lights
well okay
Bobcat says never forget 30 years ago
today the Waco Siege began the siege
ended with the deaths of more than 70
innocent men women and children
yeah I was uh not that long ago I went
down to Waco
this was uh I can't remember when we
were in we were in Austin or whatever I
think we were yeah we were in Austin
then we drove to uh Waco went to the
church
it's crazy crazy to learn about what
they were doing creepy stuff man abolish
the ATF too yup
Carlo Magno TV says Tim there's more
demons than ghosts in the Bible
well yeah
of course you know demons
somebody else's Super Chat something
about Jesus exercising demons or
something too that's interesting
glucose donor says for an old book that
doesn't have any value The Book of
Revelation seems to be getting a lot of
things correct in our society isn't that
weird who's getting more things right
Alex Jones or the Book of Revelations
that's the comparison well I think I
think the meme about Alex Jones is that
he gets a lot of things wrong but the
crazy there's a lot of crazy things he
said that bio accounts should be wrong
but turn out to be completely true and
it's like you owe the guy an apology for
assuming these things were so crazy
sounding that they weren't true and they
were true yeah
all right
toe phone man says it's going to be a
doozy when we are all treated as equal
when the good and the bad meet in the
same afterlife
perhaps
I don't know what the afterlife is going
to be like John Doyle says this Aldo guy
is very smart and handsome and cool so
true yes so true John is is uh did you
pay John to to say that about you John
that's the heck off yeah that dude's
hilarious John's the best very
intelligent man I like that guy he's
funny
Lizzie Martin says CDC and HHS does not
recognize suicide under 10 years old
they claim they don't understand intent
how many will we not know about wow man
crazy that's wild
Omega rasetsu says demons are not
spiritual entities demons are the
conceptual antithesis of coherent
Society Satan is derived from the Hebrew
word for opposition
is that true
don't know I don't know enough can't
dispute it therefore it must be true
because someone said it on the internet
there you go
all right
what do we got I'm looking at the member
chat Chris Jensen says Alex gets a lot
right he does he absolutely does but
like he went on he went on Rogan and
talked about human animal chimeras and
5G cell towers and interdimensional
beings and it's like yeah that that
one's a little much you know when he
talks about like demons in the other
Realms selling deals and stuff it's like
I can't prove any of that stuff but when
he talks about Epstein it's like oh yeah
that stuff turned out to be all uh
pretty true huh so how about that
all right
Michael galuna says take me something a
Christian and the demon bit before we
wrestle not with flesh and blood but
spirits and princip principalities in
high places Ephesians 6 12. perhaps I do
I'm just saying when you talk to someone
and their intent on doing evil and they
lie they cheat and they steal and they
are destroying everything
whether figurative or literal it falls
under the umbrella of the term demonic
you know so when Alex Jones says that
people take them literally and the media
will be like you literally thinks
they're possessed and I'm like I don't
know if he literally thinks it it's an
insult calling someone a demon is to
imply that they're an evil you know
scrupulous person
there you go
Matthew Rouse says Tim it's called The
Warp from Warhammer 40K where demons are
well okay
Raymond you Stanley Jr says IRL daytime
view Style Show can't come fast enough
perhaps it can't
no no
maybe we just do IRL earlier at some
point how about that how about we do IRL
at 4 pm instead of 8 pm
I don't know
and we'll do the morning show as well Mr
grizzly bear says Tim you're absolutely
right I drove a forklift for
Anheuser-Busch it drives me crazy that
people on the left think they are
entitled to my tax dollars that's crazy
to me you know I always tell the story
about how I walk in a vice for the first
time and not only are like half the
seats empty but people are just like
doing nothing and I'm like how much do
these people get paid it's like 50 60k a
year some of them got less some got like
30 32 but still it's like you just sit
around and then what happens like
someone emails you talking about a story
they tell you a story about how they did
ketamine while riding on a yacht with a
Bitcoin billionaire and it was a crazy
thing and then you're like I'll publish
it and then you make all that money
meanwhile the dude like breaks his hand
working in a machine shop and it's like
his insurance won't cover it
and though the people at advice are the
are more likely to be the commies who
are like we're entitled to more from the
government we should be given free stuff
and I'm like geez man yeah
all right
where are we at we'll grab some more
Super chats Daniel Smith says every
human on earth is descendant a descended
from a slave an unwilling great
grandmother and lives on lives on
conquered land also San Francisco will
ask for a federal bailout in a few years
to cover this yeah yeah there you go the
conquered land thing someone pointed out
that that's like basically blood and
soil
it is that's exactly what you're doing
yeah yeah Wyatt Anderson says Tim has my
vote
if I ever did run for office it'd
probably be for like president and it
would probably be on like a very
outrageous platform just like a totally
inviable
ridiculous platform of like
ending War shutting down the
military-industrial complex releasing
the JFK files you know like releasing
the Epstein Client List sounds good you
know and then you went to London or
would you run for a party do you think
oh man I don't know
I don't know it's a tough one
Maybe
maybe as a democratic Republican bring
back the old party from
1792 or whatever yeah and you know I I
don't know
but if I were to run I'd be like Oh I'm
just going to do all of it I'm I'm like
you know Federal Reserve gone you know
uh International Swift payment system
we're off you're all going to go back to
living on farms with chicken sorry
that's the way it's got to be there are
some merits to campaigns like that they
Advance conversation even if the
campaign itself isn't viable they they
force other people to respond to their
talking points well I'm certainly old
enough to run for president now that'd
be funny maybe I should not to actually
win but to get on debate stage in the
Republican primary and be like can we
abolish the Federal Reserve can anybody
on the stage explain to me what it does
and why it does it and why we haven't
audited it just like that's a simple
question right there you'd have any
single person right you'd have so much
Freedom they'd be like Tim can you
please answer this question be like no I
don't want to talk about that I want to
talk about why the Federal Reserve
exists that sounds pretty fun right now
because like I would just not play by
any of their rules at all there's no way
they'd let me do it I'd be up there and
they'd be like Mr pool your Economic
Policy sounds very leftist and I'd be
like that is an interesting question can
we get like out of the Middle East or
like not go to war in Ukraine anymore
can I get a show of hands of how many
people on the stage want to keep
spending hundreds of billions of
taxpayer dollars on this stuff like that
wasn't the question Tim I don't care
what you asked me next question if they
don't let you on the debate Chief you
just have this show but you respond to
the debate live and then you're
participating anyways and you probably
get a bigger viewership than the actual
debate I have a feeling that such a big
viewership if you were doing that I
would probably just being like they'd be
like Donald Trump just said that he
wants to build a big beautiful wall
restore factories to America how would
you respond to that Trump is right we
should vote for him
like I don't know what am I it's funny
how like they have to faint argument
you're you're running as Trump's hype
man not necessarily I'd be like well I
guess he's not completely wrong you know
I'd like to see him pull it off I I I
would never legitimately run you know
but if I ever got to be in a political
debate like that yeah it's funny how
they'll always feign a disagreement with
each other your tax plan doesn't go too
because it doesn't go it goes too far
well your tax plan doesn't go too far
enough and it's just like I would just
be like yeah I actually agree with like
Trump on basically everything yeah you
know that's about it there's this tweet
that was probably that was like I am
petitioning that we put a regular person
in each Olympic event so we can really
see how big I feel like your candidacy
is sort of similar like you're a person
who is pretty regular and you have a lot
of questions and so you should be able
to be on the stage to ask the questions
that everyone else has how hard would
that be how hard would it be to like
actually get on the debate stage
somewhere a Super PAC for you has
already formed as soon as you said I
would run for office they're like
because well because I'm thinking like
Michael malison the debate stage would
be way better I think you'd be more
interesting I don't know I'd probably
get really angry and start complaining
about stuff and be like y'all aren't
doing anything no one's doing anything
it's so stupid and all of the public
watching you be like I'm gonna vote for
that guy I feel that way too I hope not
I just feel like I'm sure you'd be a
wonderful president but I don't think
you'd want to be because I wouldn't be a
wonderful president you I mean I would I
wouldn't I wouldn't do the job I'd do
nothing I feel like people forget that
that might actually make it you're like
the Juan Swanson character from uh Parks
and Rec you know the greatest you know
the greatest government employee just
sits around and does nothing you know
what I would do I would live stream 24 7
7 everything that's not classified and
then any meeting that was classified I
would come out afterwards and just be
like they gave me a bunch of BS
classified justifications that didn't
justify anything so you know they were
like we should go to war in another
country and I was like well that's dumb
I don't know man I I think the reality
is people don't want a real a real
president to do the things they really
want to happen because the end result
would be the end of the Petro dollar and
then people's lives would get
substantially worse yeah so you get a
deep state that just says who cares what
they say they want their lives are
better so long as we're the system you
know in controlling the Petro dollar but
well let's do this we're gonna go to the
members only portion of the show live
over at timcast.com
so go to timcast.com click join us
become a member and then about 10 or so
minutes we will have up on the front
page the uncensored live show you can
click it and you can watch then once
that live portion wraps it will be
archived forever so you can watch it in
the library if you don't miss it if you
don't see it tonight but uh should be
fun we're slowly building out the new
members only live system so bear with us
but we got some really fun and funny
stuff to talk about we'll talk more
about what we could do to disrupt and
and change the conversation in politics
so smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the share with your
friends you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me at timcast
although do you want to shout anything
out uh yeah just follow me on my socials
at Aldo butazoni I'm actually working on
a cool new show right now called the
young entrepreneur show going to be
going to different cities around the US
and showcasing young entrepreneurs and
their products asking them how they did
it so if you're between the ages of like
14 or 23 and you feel like you got a
cool business and a cool product hit my
DMs let me know what you got going on
and uh maybe you'll be featured but
follow me that's cool I'm Hannah Globe
brimwell I'm a writer for Tim dot com
you should follow at timcast news on
Instagram and Twitter it's the best you
can follow me personally on Instagram at
handclare.b and on Twitter at HC brimlow
thanks so much
I am Phil Labonte uh the band is All
That Remains I am Phil that remains on
Twitter I am Phil that remains official
on Instagram and uh my man's search
yeah I'm at surge.com still trying to
get this mixture dialed in so follow me
on Twitter it sounded good last night
hey thanks man all right everybody we
will see you over at timcast.com in
about five or so minutes so uh stick
around and we'll see y'all there